l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement
la première d'entre elles va être posée
par Monsieur Emmanuel Bléré pour leur
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie à
villers-circimont à Gouy-en-Artois et
partout en France nos agriculteurs sont
inquiets en disant c'est 100 000
exploitations agricoles qui ont disparu
le bilan macroniste est un vaste plan
social qui ravage l'agriculture
française lors des Assises de finances
publiques ce mois-ci vous avez déclaré
faire des économies pour protéger notre
nation contre le risque de la dette
rappelons votre bilan vous avez fait 600
milliards d'euros de dettes sous le
mandat précédent et 150 milliards de
déficit au dernier PLF pour cacher votre
responsabilité vous annoncez un nouveau
plan sur le dos une fois de plus de nos
agriculteurs sous couvert d'un
verdissement de la fiscalisation sur le
gasoil non routier non paysans vos pays
plus cher leur carburant cette énergie
vous le savez et pourtant moins bien
polluante que le fioul domestique
utilisé auparavant elle dispose même
d'une part de biocarburant nos
agriculteurs monsieur le ministre ne
sont pas là pour
légèrement de exécutif oui parce que
vous souhaitez leur faire payer votre
incompétence avec un plan de 10
milliards d'euros d'économies dont il
supporterait écoute bien 15%
contraintes ceux qui font la qualité de
nos assiettes et la beauté de nos
paysages pendant que nous apportons de
plus en plus notre alimentation c'est sa
beauté toute une filière en même temps
que de mettre en danger notre
souveraineté alimentaire déjà pourtant
très impacté alors Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous vous engager pardon à vous
exclure à exclure pardon de votre plan
le génère agricole pour soutenir
véritablement la filière monsieur le
ministre les agriculteurs vous demandent
de retrouver le bon sens paysan je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre chargé
des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés bléri je constate qu'à nouveau
Vous contestez le fait que nous ayons
accumulé des déficits pendant la période
covid et donc vous contestez que nous
ayons accompagné les restaurateurs les
commerçants les artisans pendant la
période du covid avec vous il n'aurait
pas été protégé je pense qu'ils seront
heureux de le savoir
je crois qu'il y a un consensus
aujourd'hui très large sur la nécessité
de sortir des énergies fossiles qu'il
s'agisse de notre pays ou de l'Europe et
la question du GNR vous le savez elle a
été largement débattue dans cette
émission et elle a été votée sa
suppression pour les usages non
agricoles en 2019 dans cette émission sa
suppression ayant été reportée à
plusieurs reprises depuis lors
aujourd'hui on est dans un système où
les français payent deux fois ils payent
d'abord de la dépense fiscale avec les
dispositifs qui existent aujourd'hui ils
payent sur des carburants qui polluent
notre planète et l'environnement il paye
ensuite pour réparer la pollution qui a
été engendrée par cette dépense fiscale
faut être donc cohérent et disposer de
leviers qui nous permettent de financer
la transition écologique c'est en ce
sens qu'il a été annoncé par Bruno Le
Maire que de manière très progressive à
horizon 2030 nous allions revenir sur
cette niche fiscale du gazole non
routier évidemment ça doit se faire à la
fois en cohérence et en responsabilité
la cohérence
c'est la cohérence que nous devons avoir
par rapport à nos objectifs climatiques
et au fait de sortir des énergies
fossiles et la responsabilité c'est
évidemment de ne pas plonger des
secteurs économiques ou agricoles dans
de grandes difficultés par cette
décision c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a engagé un travail de concertation
d'échange avec l'ensemble des filières
concernées qu'il s'agisse du BTP de
l'agriculture du transport routier avec
Bruno Le Maire avec les ministres
concernés et Marc fenaux en premier lieu
s'agissant de l'agriculture ce travail
va nous mener dans l'hémicycle ici cet
automne à avoir un débat sur le
calendrier que nous proposerons pour la
suppression de la niche GNR dont je
rappelle qui sera extrêmement progressif
l'enjeu à nouveau cette protéger notre
planète mais évidemment d'être
responsable pour nos secteurs
économiques
merci beaucoup monsieur bléri merci
madame le Président je pense monsieur le
ministre que c'est surtout fait pour
faire les poches de nos paysans vous
êtes en train d'appliquer ce qu'on
appelle la politique de la zigzag est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est la politique
de la zigzag c'est celle qui consiste à
se dire si à bordure ces quatre
trottoirs et vous avancez ainsi ça ne
marche pas comme ça la France a besoin
d'un véritable plan et notamment nos
agriculteurs ce qui nourrissent nos
bouches merci
je vous remercie
mes chers collègues je suis heureuse de
souhaiter un votre nom la bienvenue à
une délégation du groupe d'amitié
Mexique France de la Chambre des députés
des États-Unis du Mexique conduites par
son Président Monsieur Roberto Carlos
Lopez Garcia
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Maxime Lainé pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre panière une hachée chers
collègues après une augmentation du coût
de la vie de 6% après une nouvelle
hausse des loyers autorisés de trois et
demi pour cent c'est une énième attaque
contre le pouvoir d'achat que vous allez
mener avec la suppression des tarifs
réglementés du gaz au 30 juin et
l'abandon du bouclier tarifaire une
suppression qui frappera plus de 2
millions de nos concitoyens contraint à
une sobriété pas du tout raisonnable
mais bel et bien subie déjà en 2022 plus
de 800 000 procédures ont été lancées
pour impayés soit une hausse de 10%,
cela ne vous suffit pas alors que le
Médiateur de l'énergie lui-même met en
garde sur les contrats à prix ajuster au
marché vous décidez d’exposer les
familles à l'extrême volatilité des prix
sur les marchés du gaz des tarifs qui
ont doublé depuis 2004 et qu'il était
dernier était 20 fois supérieur à ce
qu'ils étaient observés quelques
semaines plus tôt en appliquant bêtement
les règles de concurrence européenne
vous préférez prendre nos concitoyens en
otage d'un marché qui ne marche pas
plutôt que de les protéger contre cette
nouvelle bombe sociale vous préférez
conforter les rendent des
multinationales de l'énergie vous
préférez protéger la liberté des
ultra-riches de brûler du kérosène dans
leur jet privé tandis que le plus grand
nombre devra bientôt choisir entre faire
cuire ses pattes ou se chauffer
quel rustine allez-vous devoir encore
inventer pour pallier votre entêtement
idéologique n'avez-vous donc rien
compris du message de nos concitoyens
depuis les gilets jaunes leur exigence
de vivre dignement pas seulement
survivre l'énergie c'est la vie c'est un
bien commun et c'est un droit vous
voulez imiter le CNR mais vous liquidez
les conquis sociaux issus de la
Libération dont font partie les tarifs
réglementés alors je vous le demande
solennellement madame la ministre
allez-vous comme le demande plus de 30
000 personnes par une signature en ligne
renoncer à cette nouvelle casse à cette
nouvelle injustice sociale je vous
remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
hachée ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
l'aîné vous comparez la fin des terres
Vegas et une libéralisation de marché
mais monsieur ne le député cessé de
mentir l'éther vegan ils évoluent chaque
mois au rythme des prix du marché c'est
un index qui est fondé sur le prix du
marché contrairement à ce que vous
prétendez quand les prix se sont envolés
ce sont c'est le bouclier gaz qui a mis
en place cette majorité qui a protégé
les Français d'une augmentation des prix
du gaz il a permis d'éviter des hautes
massives de plus de 120%, la France
insoumise a-t-elle voté ce bouclier gaz
vous n'avez pas voté la seule mesure
efficace pour éviter cette envolée des
prix alors maintenant vous parlez au
moment où les prix ont redescendu c'est
ça la vérité vous n'avez pas voté une
seule des mesures de protection en
faveur des Français des entreprises des
collectivités locales boucliers
tarifaires électricité non bouclier
tarifaire gaz non chaque énergie
exceptionnelle non chaque bois chaque
fioul filet de sécurité mais vous ne
vous arrêtez pas là s'il vous plaît vous
refusez d'agir pour libérer notre pays
de sa dépendance aux énergies fossiles
avez-vous voté pour l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables
procédures sur le nucléaire
monsieur le député derrière vos belles
paroles il y a la détestation dogmatique
du nucléaire votre préférence pour le
gaz russe et le charbon allemand votre
refus de rendre notre pays plus
indépendant d'un point de vue
énergétique alors laissez cette majorité
travailler et protéger les Français
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Henri
alphandari pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse au mini chargé de l'Industrie
monsieur le ministre je souhaite appeler
votre attention sur la situation
d'incertitude vécue par beaucoup de
chefs d'entreprise et chefs
d'exploitation de la circonscription au
regard des tarifs des fournisseurs
d'énergie et de la mise en oeuvre des
aides votées par cette assemblée cette
situation nous sommes nombreux sur ces
bancs à l'entendre si les aides
apportées ont largement bénéficié aux
acteurs économiques qui les ont perçus
de nombreuses entreprises sous contrôle
ont été à des régularisations intenables
pour leur trésorerie et sont à court
terme menacés de fermeture pour rappel
le prix de nombreux contrats sera ajusté
à la fin de l'année afin d'appliquer un
prix moyen d'électricité sur l'année
2023 à la consommation effective du
bénéficiaire or des reprises mensuelles
sont constatées dès à présent les
entreprises et les exploitations
concernées se retrouvent donc avec des
sommes à ajouter à leur facturation
normale et ne peuvent tout simplement
pas honorer les sommes demandées
certains chefs d'entreprises éligibles à
des mesures de soutien se sont trompés
de dispositifs ou non plus s'en saisir
pleinement toutes ces entreprises sont
en danger imminent et avec elle leurs
emplois et leur savoir-faire par
ailleurs nous allons préparer le
prochain hiver et nous
approvisionnements de larges mouvements
tectoniques sont à l'oeuvre
bouleversement géopolitique augmentation
des transactions libellées en uan
difficulté d'approvisionnement en
énergie ce contexte de tension sur les
ressources pourrait maintenir des
tendances inflationnistes ma question
est doux monsieur le ministre à court
terme pouvez-vous nous dire ce que nous
devons expliquer à nos entrepreneurs sur
la difficulté de lisibilité des factures
et de gestion de trésorerie liés aux
reprises mensuelles de boucliers ou
d'amortisseurs à moyen terme ces
dispositifs s'éteignants et sachant
qu'en l'état nous ne souhaitons pas les
renouveler quelle mesure envisagez-vous
pour que les consommations électriques
soient à des niveaux supportables pour
une large partie de notre issue
économique
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député merci de votre question qui nous
permet de rappeler d'abord que les
mesures votées par cette majorité pour
faire face à un défi absolument
historique l'hiver dernier des
préhistoriquesmentaux des
préhistoriquement volatiles du fait de
la situation internationale ont été une
stratégie gagnante vous l'avez dit nous
avons protégé les ménages comme nulle
part ailleurs en Europe nous avons
protégé les entreprises aussi comme
nulle part en Europe et nous avons
adapté notre outil de production
énergétique électrique et gaz à la
situation actuelle je voudrais en
profiter pour saluer et remercier les
personnels d'EDF qui ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour remettre à niveau
l'appareil nucléaire et aussi les
personnels de Total énergie qui
travaillent pour construire et c'est
important dans la perspective de l'hiver
prochain un terminal méthanier flottant
qui va nous permettre d'assurer une une
un approvisionnement en gaz de qualité
pour l'hiver prochain
alors d'abord vous m'interrogez sur
l'hiver prochain évidemment même si la
situation s'est extrêmement améliorée
aujourd'hui les prix ont retrouvé des
niveaux normaux nous ne devons pas
dormir sur nos deux oreilles et préparer
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
divers prochains un en continuant à
négocier et c'est madame la ministre de
la transition énergétique qui s'en
occupe l'évolution du fonctionnement du
marché de l'énergie
du charbon allemand ou d'autres
ressources internationales et d'autre
part nous devons traiter les cas
d'espèces vous en avez mentionné
certains qui font qu'aujourd'hui
certaines entreprises font face à des
facturations anormales dans l'immense
majorité les fournisseurs d'énergie on
appliqué directement les restos en liés
au bouclier énergétique que vous avez
voté sur les factures énergétiques vous
l'avez dit un certain nombre de
consommateurs font face aujourd'hui à
des incompréhensions face à des factures
dans lequel clairement des erreurs ont
été commises de ce point de vue là une
solution dans chaque département
nous avons un commissaire départemental
aux sorties de crise qui est là pour les
aider c'est commissaires accompagnent
déjà plus de 10 000 entreprises qui font
face à ces défis n'hésitez pas à les y
envoyer il les aideront pour que ces
erreurs puissent être corrigées merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
neige laine pour le groupe yacht merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
le printemps et l'été voit fleurir les
déplacements de caravane des gens du
voyage des aires d'accueil ont été payés
par les collectivités et donc par les
impôts de nos concitoyens pour les
accueillir même sans cela et malgré les
efforts fait nous constatons encore
toujours des implantations de manière
illégale et de manière brutale chez les
particuliers ou sur des terrains
communaux c'est le cas dans le Nord chez
notre collègue Guy Bricout comme c'est
le cas depuis hier chez moi dans les
Vosges dans la commune du syndicat 24
caravanes forçant leur installation dans
le champ d'un agriculteur qui venait
juste de finir de le faucher monsieur le
ministre mes questions sont simples
comment expliquons-nous à nos
associations qu'on le refuse une
manifestation parce qu'elles ont oublié
un simple papier comment expliquons-nous
alors même que nous nous sommes en
danger d'incendie que nous laissons 200
caravanes s'installer sur du foie sec
comment explique-t-on que nous devons
faire attention à notre environnement et
que nous allons devoir tout un terrain
et de la forêt souillé par des déchets
dans une zone classique Natura 2000 et
dans un périmètre servant de captage
d'eau comment expliquer à nos
collectivité que dans ce tableau
semblait tous les jours nous les
soutenons et laisser les mairies celle
du syndicat dans ce cas précis et son
maire Pascal Claude a puissant face à
cette envahissement pour finir comment
explique-t-on à tous nos concitoyens à
quel point il faut respecter la loi pour
le bien commun et qu'en fin de compte
nous les ont nous laissons agir
impunément ceux qui ne la respectent pas
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le Président
de
je sais qu'il est bien difficile pour
les élus locaux de faire face à
l'arrivée d'occupation illégale vous
évoquez
vous évoquez ici ceux des gens du voyage
je voudrais vous rappeler la loi et je
voudrais vous dire ce que le
gouvernement compte faire la loi c'est
qu'il faut évidemment être en pleine et
vous le savez l'égalité de la loi Besson
1 et Besson 2 qui oblige les
collectivités locales les départements
les intercommunalités et des communes à
avoir des heures d'accueil des gens du
voyage sinon même fondé les gendarmes
les policiers ne peuvent pas procéder à
l'expulsion à la demande de l'autorité
judiciaire
il se peut que par ailleurs des trous
sont dans la raquette pour empêcher les
policiers les gendarmes de venir comme
par exemple lorsque le maire ou le
propriétaire ne porte pas à plainte dans
le délai de flagrance ce qui explique
pourquoi les gendarmes et les policiers
ne peuvent intervenir qu'après une
décision de justice forcément longue
sans doute faut-il corriger ça nous
travaillons avec Christophe Béchu vos
collectionneurs ont travaillé sur une
proposition de loi sur lequel nous
allons proposer de continuer à faire
évoluer la législation et d'autre part
il se peut que les caravanes
s'installent sur des terrains dont on ne
connaît pas le propriétaire ou le
propriétaire ne porte pas plainte
lui-même peut-être contre rétribution
parfois contre non rétribution il faut
laisser Homer même s'il s'agit d'une
propriété privée ou au préfet le soin
évidemment de se substituer pour déposer
plainte afin de pouvoir libérer l'action
judiciaire qui nous permet de faire
évacuer ces personnes bien évidemment je
partage de ce député
la colère des habitants et des hélico
pour en avoir été pendant très longtemps
qui a su à la fois faire une heure
d'accueil des gens du voyage et obtenir
les difficultés que vous évoquez mais je
peux vous promettre qu'avec le ministre
Christophe Béchu nous allons proposer
bientôt un texte
issu de vos collègues sénateurs merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno millienne pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre chargé
du renouveau démocratique porte-parole
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
Journal du Dimanche n'est pas paru
dimanche l'ensemble de la rédaction
ayant décidé de faire grève pour
protester contre la nomination d'un
nouveau directeur de la publication aux
opinions bien affirmées madame la mise
de la culture c'est d'ailleurs elle-même
de la situation à l'arrivée à la tête du
JDD d'un homme qui dirigeait il y a peu
un journal condamné pour un jurassiste
cette nomination est le symptôme d'un
mouvement plus général comme pour
d'autres médias elle remet en question
l'indépendance des rédactions et la
pluralité de la presse depuis la
consécration de la liberté de la presse
par la loi 1881 le législateur a
régulièrement encadré ce qui est l'un
des piliers de notre régime démocratique
sans en altérer la force nos
prédécesseurs ont ainsi réussi à assurer
l'indépendance des journalistes ou
encore la lutte contre la manipulation
de l'information sont dénaturer ou
affaiblir cette liberté fondamental je
vous le dis clairement j'ai aujourd'hui
l'impression que la situation nous
échappe jamais depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et l'ordonnance
interdisant la concentration des organes
de presse nous n'avons assisté à une
stratégie aussi agressive de Miss sous
tutelle idéologique de notre paysage
médiatique cette situation quasiment
inédite pose clairement la question de
l'indépendance des titres de presse
vis-à-vis du pouvoir économique la
question de la concentration du capital
dans les mains d'un seul homme mais
aussi le rôle que dois-je élarcom pour
garantir la pluralité des opinions ma
question est donc la suivante face aux
nouveaux défis que doit affronter notre
paysage médiatique comment pouvons-nous
continuer d'assurer l'indépendance
journalistique et le pluralisme des
opinions seul garant d'une information
éclairée de nos concitoyens
indispensables au maintien d'une
démocratie qui fonctionne je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la partie Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Bruno Millien merci pour votre question
évidemment le gouvernement n'ignore pas
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au JDD et
les craintes que cela peut soulever de
toutes parts bien sûr monsieur le député
la presse d'opinion elle est légale en
France et ceux au nom du pluralisme des
médias et de la liberté de la presse qui
sont des principes fondamentaux dans
notre démocratie mais les inquiétudes
sont vives je le disais dans une partie
de la profession la ministre de la
Culture n'a pas attendu l'actualité
récente pour se saisir de ces sujets de
protection du pluralisme libre
information de respect de l'indépendance
éditoriale qu'elle avait d'ailleurs
identifié dès son arrivée il y a un an
en janvier par exemple à la réuni des
parlementaires pour engager la réflexion
et vous associez aux réflexions sur une
évolution de la loi Bloch qui date de
2016 et qui vise à renforcer la liberté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme des
médias la présidente de la commission
des affaires culturelles madame Isabelle
roche c'est également saisie mobilisé à
travers une mission d'évaluation de la
loi qui est en cours elle co-rapportait
par un député du groupe socialiste
monsieur Inaki et shanise et cette
mission est déjà au travail alors est-ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin que ce qui
existe déjà dans la loi comme les
chartes déontologiques les comités
relatifs à l'honnêteté à l'indépendance
et au pluralisme de l'information et des
programmes proposés de personnalités
indépendantes le droit actuel de
comporte par exemple aucune disposition
de nature à garantir l'indépendance des
rédactions à l'égard des tentatives
d'influence ou d'émission de la part
d'actionnaires je ne doute pas que les
travaux et les auditions à venir nous
permettront d'avancer ensemble afin de
déterminer des évolutions si elles sont
nécessaires le gouvernement souhaite
réfléchir à comment garantir renforcer
les garanties indispensables à notre
démocratie qui s'incarne aussi dans la
diversité des opinions toutes les pistes
sont donc ouvertes vous le savez
monsieur le député le président de la
République a d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il y
aura des états généraux de l'information
qui seront les bienvenus pour aborder
l'ensemble des problématiques l'ensemble
des problématiques n'ayez pas peur de se
les députés relatives un information une
valeur si cher dans notre pays merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
jumelles pour le coco démocrate et
républicaine
madame la présidente madame la ministre
avec l'inflation les Français sont
assommés assommés
par l'explosion des prix de
l'électricité assommé par votre flux de
logique de compenser l'inflation par la
rémunération du travail le salaire
malgré cela le 1er juillet prochain
votre gouvernement rajoute une louche en
franchissant un nouveau câble dans la
libéralisation du marché de l'énergie
avec la fin des tarifs réglementés de
vente du gaz ainsi près de 7 millions de
Français vont subir directement la
jungle spéculative autour du prix du gaz
le quoi qu'il en coûte décidément et bel
et bien fini pour la France qui
travaille nous l'avons mesuré le
bouclier tarifaire pour les prix de
l'énergie et en particulier ceux du gaz
ne protège pas les locataires HLM ni
même ce vivant en copropriété
avec la fin des tarifs réglementés de
vente du gaz le 1er juillet quel
français pourra se sentir protégé alors
que les prix fixés sur les contrats pour
la chaudière pour la maison dépendront
de l'humeur de la Bourse votre manière
de faire coup de chair elle nourrit les
marchands de savonnettes de l'énergie
mais elle ne préserve pas le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages or je le redis
l'énergie n'est pas une marchandise elle
est un bien de première nécessité
renoncez donc à votre rêve de
transformer des Français en trader de
l'énergie c'est pourquoi madame la
ministre le groupe GDR sa composante
communiste avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales mais aussi avec
l'ensemble des associations de
consommateurs vous demandent
solennellement le retour au tarif
réglementé du gaz et de l'électricité
merci merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Agnès manière de
la transition énergétique merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
jumelle comme je l'ai indiqué à
l'instant à Monsieur le Député l'aîné
les tarifs réglementés du gaz ne sont
pas un tarif plafonné c'est un tarif de
marché il évolue chaque mois sur une
référence de marché les marchés
internationaux il est donc extrêmement
volatile et ce n'est pas lui qui protège
je rappelle également et donc que change
concrètement cette fin des tarifs
réglementés d'abord je rappelle que elle
concerne un quart des consommateurs qui
utilisent aujourd'hui du gaz nous leur
avons écrit pour les rassurer les
informer sur les options qui s'offrent à
eux première option rester chez leur
fournisseur actuel et basculer
automatiquement sur une offre que nous
avons que nous appelons offre passer
Kenji a mis en place à notre demande
demande du gouvernement cette offre elle
s'appuie sur un indice repère que la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie a
créé à ma demande les prix du gaz étant
actuellement redescendu les Français qui
souscriront à cette offre passerelle
bénéficier Chiron d'un tarif de 10 à 20
% moins cher moins cher que le l'été le
tarif réglementé c'est la réalité du
moment deuxième option ils peuvent
signer un nouveau contrat ils peuvent
signer un nouveau contrat avant le
premier juillet avec le fournisseur de
leur choix aucune autre démarche n’est
nécessaire il n'y a aucun risque de
coupure et aucun changement de compteur
donc je le redis aujourd'hui l'offre
passerelle c'est 10 à 20% de moins que
le coût du tarif réglementé par ailleurs
le gouvernement et la majorité continue
de soutenir les Français les plus en
difficulté des fins 2021 les chèques
énergie exceptionnelle on bénéficié à 12
millions de Français ce sont également
5,6 millions de ménages qui bénéficient
automatiquement de la nouvelle campagne
de chaque énergie madame jusqu'à 277
euros merci je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur jumelle
madame la ministre vous ne manquez pas
de poupée vous nous répondez sur le prix
du gaz aujourd'hui alors que vous savez
que les marchands de savonnettes vont
spéculer sur la vie des gens au cœur de
l'hiver en faisant en sorte que
l'addition salée du prix du gaz du prix
de l'électricité empêche les ménages de
faire bouillir la marmite et de se
chauffer au cœur de l'hiver décidément
vous n'êtes pas à l'écoute de la France
d'en bas merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Madame Natalia poudirez
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine Colonna le monde a été
témoin de la tentative de putsch menée
par le chef du groupe Wagner Prigogine
et de ses troupes cette même milice que
l'Assemblée nationale à l'initiative du
groupe Renaissance appelé inscrire sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
le Kremlin semble reprendre la main
cependant
la réaction du président Poutine
évoquant 1917 et la guerre civile montre
combien cette tentative a été prise au
sérieux elle révèle particulièrement les
fractures au sein de l'appareil
sécuritaire russe et la guerre des clans
qui s'y jouent la crise dans laquelle a
été plongée la Russie pendant deux jours
laisse envisager une bataille de
succession sous forme d'une transition
chaotique et violente il est
vraisemblable néanmoins que seule une
défaite sévère en Ukraine ne souhaite
nature à déstabiliser ce régime
autoritaire si les conséquences du coup
de force de prégoji ne reste difficile à
évaluer à ce stade la fragilité avérée
du chef du Kremlin questionne sa
crédibilité comme interlocuteur pour
négocier une paix durable avec l'Ukraine
s'agissant d'affaires intérieur à la
Russie les dirigeant occidentaux se sont
montrés à juste titre prudent le
président français a notamment rappelé
que la situation justifie pleinement le
soutien que nous apportons aux
Ukrainiens
la stabilité croissante en Russie ainsi
que leur repositionnement potentiel des
troubles de Wagner en Biélorussie
suscitent l'inquiétude de certains de
nos alliés devons-nous de ce fait
redouté une déstabilisation accrue dans
la région plus largement et malgré les
zones d'eau d'ombre qui demeurent que
pouvez-vous nous dire des échanges qui
ont eu lieu entre les membres du G7 et
l'Union européenne concernant
d'éventuels répercussions sur la guerre
en Ukraine je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Madame Catherine Colonna ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
vous irez en effet vous l'avez dit la
première chose qu'il faille dire c'est
que ces événements du week-end rejoint
celle de nombreuses zones d'ombres et
sans doute leurs conséquences dont elles
pas finies de se faire sentir mais ils
ont à l'évidence mis en lumière des
fissures des fractures et même j'ai déjà
utilisé expressions des failles au sein
du système russe et celle-ci sont très
largement dues à la guerre que fait la
Russie à l'Ukraine nous avons mené
madame la députée au cours des derniers
jours de nombreuses consultations le
président de la République avec
notamment ces homologues du quad et pour
ma part avec mes homologues du G7 avec
ceux de l'Union européenne avec mon
homologue ukrainien et il y a quelques
instants avec les trois pays baltes
alors d'abord je le répète nous n'avons
en rien l'attention de nos émisser dans
ce qui est une affaire intérieure russe
mais notre responsabilité notre
responsabilité reste plus que jamais
donc continuer d'être extrêmement
vigilant et de continuer à aider
l'Ukraine à se défendre vigilance et
aide qui sont plus que jamais
nécessaires dans ce moment d'instabilité
nouvelle la stabilité qui est causée par
la Russie et dont elle-même commence à
voir les conséquences sur elles-mêmes
avec mes trois homologues des pays
baltes je le disais tout à l'heure ils
sont à Paris nous avons réaffirmé que
cette guerre met la Russie dans une
impasse une impasse militaire économique
diplomatique morale évidemment mais
désormais aussi une impasse intérieure
alors elle doit comprendre elle la
Russie doit comprendre que le temps ne
joue pas pour elle que nous restons aux
côtés de l'Ukraine et que le coût de son
agression contre l'Ukraine va continuer
d'augmenter pour elle elle doit
comprendre qu'elle doit rendre à
l'Ukraine la paix et la souveraineté qui
sont les siennes il est temps il est
plus que temps je vous remercie madame
la députée merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Marleix pour le groupe les républicains
le collectif des isabelle a demandé au
Conseil d'État l'annulation de l'article
premier des statuts de la fédération
française de football qui interdit toute
nue manifestant ostensiblement une
appartenance religieuse le rapporteur du
Conseil d'État propose de leur donner
raison il faut avoir la naïveté d'une
pâquerette pour refuser de voir dans ce
mouvement du prosélytisme ou de la
provocation j'ai eu la curiosité de
regarder sur internet que chacun de nos
compatriotes peut faire la tenue
vestimentaire des équipes de football
féminine d'un certain nombre de grands
pays musulmans l'équipe de football du
Maroc pas de hijab l'équipe de football
féminine d'Algérie pas de hijab l'équipe
de football féminine de Tunisie pas de
hijab l'équipe de football féminine du
Sénégal pas de hijab en 2004 après la
querelle du voile à l'école le président
Chirac dont l'amitié et le respect pour
de nombreux pays musulmans n'étaient pas
un secret a eu le courage de légiférer
pour conserver à l'école son statut de
sanctuaire républicain si dans trois
semaines le Conseil d'État suit son
rapporteur serez-vous prêtes à suivre
l'exemple du président Chirac et
allégiféré pour mettre nos enceintes
sportives à l'abri du prosélytisme
religieux
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix
je veux avant toute chose réaffirmer mon
attachement et celui de tout mon
gouvernement au strict respect du
principe de laïcité
mais vous m'interrogez sur une affaire
actuellement en délibérée suite à
l'audience publique qui s'est tenue hier
et vous le savez monsieur le Président
marlex je ne saurais m'exprimer sur une
affaire en cours le Conseil d'État fait
son travail en toute indépendance et
imparti impartialité et cette séparation
des pouvoirs est au cœur de notre
République mais monsieur le Président je
mesure parfaitement les interrogations
que suscite cette affaire nous attendons
la décision et nous accompagnerons la
Fédération Française de foot et les
autres fédérations autant que de besoin
et monsieur le Président quel que soit
la décision je peux vous assurer que je
suis totalement mobilisé avec la
ministre des Sports Amélie ou des à
Castera pour le respect strict de nos
principes républicains dans le sport en
particulier la laïcité et la neutralité
du service public
nous sommes mobilisés pour garantir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
notamment dans le sport
nous sommes mobilisés pour lutter contre
toutes les formes de prosélytisme et de
radicalisation et avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin et la
ministre des Sports nous sommes en
première ligne pour combattre toutes les
formes de séparatisme dans les clubs
3500 clubs ont été contrôlés en 2022
dont une trentaine ont donné lieu à des
mesures pour mettre fin à des dérives
séparatistes nous allons renforcer les
contrôles à la rentrée et nous
n'hésiterons pas à fermer des clubs qui
promènent promovent une idéologie
radicale ou séparatiste enfin la
ministre des Sports signera dans les
prochaines semaines des partenariats
avec les fédérations pour renforcer la
formation des référents lutte contre les
séparatisme et les atteintes à la
laïcité monsieur le Président Marleix
j'ai toute confiance en nous club et en
nous instance sport pour faire respecter
nos règles et nos principes républicains
et le gouvernement restera pleinement
mobilisé à leur côté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre monsieur le Président Madame la
première Mini je vous ai posé une
question simple aide vous prête à
légiférer comme l'avait fait le
président Chirac vous n'avez pas répondu
à cette question pourtant extrêmement
simple nous n'en serions pas non plus
dans cette situation si votre
gouvernement le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin avait accepté les
amendements du groupe des Républicains
en 2021 sur la loi séparatiste vous les
avez rejetés et vous vous convertissez
aujourd'hui tardivement madame Premier
ministre nous serons au rendez-vous nous
déposerons un texte pour que nos pour
préserver la neutralité de nos anciens
sportives
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
Garraud pour le groupe socialiste merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Redon vous y est
omnas Périgueux et nous l'avons appris
hier j'associe d'ailleurs mon collègue
Yannick Favennec en Mayenne plus aucun
hôpital n'assura les urgences la nuit
durant l'été sauf les urgences vitales
c'est ça votre bilan depuis 6 ans alors
que vous nous expliquez que tout est
sous contrôle et que ça finira par aller
mieux mais nous le savons et vous le
savez c'est tout l'inverse ce que nous
vivons dans le pays c'est une
dégradation sans précédent dans l'accès
aux soins et de la situation des
hôpitaux depuis le 1er décembre 2021
selon SAMU urgence de France
36 000 patients ont dormi sur un
brancard sans chambre attribuées alors
bien sûr et je veux le dire le problème
ne date pas d'hier et chacun porte une
part de responsabilité mais madame la
Première ministre votre responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est d'agir et d'agir
vraiment or je veux rappeler quand même
que le Ségur de la santé n'a pas produit
le choc d'attractivité qui était annoncé
pour les métiers du soin je veux aussi
rappeler que vous avez refusé toute
régulation de l'installation des
médecins libéraux pour mieux les
répartir sur le territoire national
comme le proposait notre groupe de
travail transpartisan et je veux
rappeler aussi et c'est pire que vous
diminuez les remboursements de certains
médicaments et de certains soins
dentaires ceux qui provoquera à coup sûr
du renoncement aux soins
madame la Première ministre notre
hôpital brûle et vous regardez ailleurs
et c'est l'ensemble de notre système de
santé qui craque de partout madame la
Première ministre quant allez vous
prendre la mesure de l'urgence merci
coucou mon cher collègue la parole est à
Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre en
charge de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Guillaume
Garou vous m'interrogez sur la
problématique des urgences en Mayenne
vous le savez grâce à la mobilisation de
tous les professionnels et afin de faire
face à une huile sur les tensions en
ressources de professionnels de santé
qui touche à la fois les établissements
de santé mais aussi les organisations
libérales du territoire les
professionnels se sont
regroupés avec la Fédération
interhospitalière afin d'apporter une
réponse pour cet été les urgences seront
effectivement fermées de 18h30 à 8h mais
je tiens à le dire que les urgences
vitales les urgences vitales seront
assurées 7 jours sur tête et 24
heures sur 24 comme l'été dernier nous
nous pouvons remercier l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé de ce mobiliser
à la fois ceux de la ville et ceux de
l'hôpital afin d'assurer à travers le
service d'accès aux soins une régulation
qui permet de répondre à tous les appels
qui sont donnés aux 15 c'est tout
l'enjeu du déploiement du service
d'accès aux soins qui d'ailleurs a été
évalué par les gaz et qui est étendu à
tout le territoire donc monsieur le
député je tiens vraiment à le dire les
urgences vitales et il est important de
le signaler à nos concitoyens seront
bien assurés 24 heures sur 24 enfin nous
tenons à dire que le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé notamment au service
des urgences avec le doublement des
rémunérations des gardes et la
majoration des heures de nuit le sujet
de la régulation que vous avez ok de
nouveau à travers votre question a été
tranchée il y a quelques jours ici dans
un hémicycle avec un vote vous savez la
régulation n'est pas la réponse aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens que
ce soit à la ville ou à l'hôpital c'est
bien tout un panel de mesure que nous
sommes en train de prendre et nous
aurons l'occasion dans les prochains
jours de faire de nouvelles annonces
pour répondre aux besoins de santé de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Sophie tailler
polluant pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
exprimer tout mon soutien et tout notre
soutien au journaliste du journal du
dimanche
ce qui ne les soutiennent pas et qui
appelle aussi à la privatisation du
service public de l'audiovisuel ce sont
les mêmes ce ne sont pas des
républicains je le dis car la liberté de
la presse a pluralité sont des éléments
fondamentaux de la démocratie
l'information est un bien public protégé
par notre Constitution c'est ce qui
différencie un journal d'une agence de
com
le milliardaire à Vincent Bolloré il
suffit de sortir le porte-monnaie pour
acheter les médias un un et y imposer
ses intérêts économiques et sa croisade
idéologique à chaque fois la même
recette management autoritaire
intervention directe sur la ligne
éditoriale censure partout où il passe
il vire les journalistes qui font du
travail de terrain et qui sont attachés
à la déontologie pour les remplacer par
ces chroniqueurs d'extrême droite cet
homme qui utilise les médias pour
imposer son projet politique
pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente
pardonner mon expression mais il se fout
de notre gueule cet homme oui il se il
se joue de notre attentisme au Sénat
sous serment il déclarait qu'il
n'interviendrait pas dans la nomination
des dirigeants des médias et que fait-il
à peine quelques semaines quelques mois
plus tard il nomme le responsable de la
condamnation de valeurs actuelles pour
un Jura caractère raciste à la tête du
JDD alors le gouvernement ne peut pas se
contenter uniquement d'un tweet de la
ministre de la Culture pour exprimer ses
regrets quand organiserez-vous enfin les
états généraux de l'information que vous
repoussez depuis plus d'un an
je déposerai dans les prochains jours
une proposition de loi pour donner un
droit de regard au journaliste sur la
nomination de leur directeur de
rédaction comme le propose un collectif
d'universitaire et des déditeurs dont
Julien cachet et Joseph stiglit la
soutiendrez-vous le seul moyen de
défendre la liberté de la presse c'est
défendre les journalistes merci beaucoup
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre en
charge du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés mesdames la
députée taillée paulion j'excuse Rima
abdulmanach la mise de la culture est
actuellement en déplacement au côté du
président de la République à Marseille
mais dans cet enceinte madame la députée
c'est le ministre de la République qui
vous répondra sans tenant strictement à
ce qu'est et exige l'État de droit
d'abord en démocratie les médias sont
indépendants le rôle de l'État c'est de
soutenir le pluralisme le rôle de la
justice c'est de sanctionner les actes
répréhensibles lorsqu'il y en a imaginez
seulement madame la députée un monde
dans lequel le Ministre en charge la
culture déciderait de retirer ses
responsabilités un directeur de
rédaction je ne doute pas c'est pas ce
que vous dites ne finit pas ce n'est
évidemment pas si vous souhaitez et
j'espère que l'Assemblée nationale
serait devant debout contre une telle
décision car c'est cette même Assemblée
nationale qui a déclaré en 1789 que la
libre communication des pensées et des
opinions se fait dans le stric le
respect de la loi c'est un des droits
les plus précieux de l'homme et
d'ajouter en 1881 dans une loi
fondatrice sur la liberté de la presse
l'imprimerie et la librairie sont libres
libres l'État est garant de cette
liberté et si liberté est censure sont
de parfaites anthonymes liberté et
pluralisme se conjuguent eux
naturellement ainsi en 2021 plus de 400
titres en bénéficié d'aide direct ou
indirecte libération la croix l'humanité
le Figaro alternative économique
causette et même fakir toute une série
évidemment de médias régionaux ont
bénéficié de subventions publiques vous
connaissez le rôle de l'État celui de la
justice quant aux journalistes tiens à
rappeler dans le cadre de cette
assemblée les principes de la Charte de
Munich de 1971 dont les journalistes
français ont été les principaux artisans
parmi les droits et les devoirs
continuant cette charte j'en retiens un
notamment ne jamais confondre son métier
avec celui du publicitaire ou celui du
propagandiste je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Marc ferrachi
pour logo Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre ce ne
sont certainement pas les parlementaires
les ministres les élus qui ont à définir
la ligne éditoriale d'un média et ça
n'est pas non plus le rôle d'un
actionnaire car si nous sommes
profondément attachés à la liberté
économique nous sommes également
convaincus que le respect de
l'indépendance éditoriale des
journalistes est un principe essentiel
aller à la liberté de la presse on
pourrait juger comme une péripétie de la
vie des médias la nomination à la tête
du Journal du Dimanche de l'ancien
directeur de la rédaction de
l'hebdomadaire d'extrême droite valeur
actuelle mais peut-on parler de
péripéties lorsque le responsable d'un
titre de presse condamné en appel pour
un jeu raciste prend la direction d'un
journal qui depuis 75 ans qu'on l'aime
ou qu'on l'aime pas qu'on le lise ou
qu'on ne le lise pas est attaché à la
diversité des opinions peut-on parler de
péripéties lorsque plus de 30 sociétés
des créateurs représentant la presse
française dans ses sensibilités diverses
se déclarent inquiète de cette
nomination et affirme leur soutien à la
rédaction du Journal du Dimanche peut-on
parler de péripéties lorsque tout ceci
s'inscrit dans un contexte de
concentration des médias qui justifie
peut-être que le législateur prenne
demain ces responsabilités pour
renforcer le cadre légal certains
pourraient invoquer ici le principe de
la liberté d'entreprendre mais il n'y a
pas derrière les rachats de médias la
démarche de création d'une entreprise de
presse il s'agit parfois d'acquérir des
chaînes ou des journaux auxquelles leur
audience est attachée par la force de
l'habitude puis de changer la
composition de la rédaction afin de
faire prévaloir la ligne éditoriale de
l'actionnaire
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Veyron ministre délégué chargé
du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés Monsieur le Député
Marc Ferracci peut-être pour reprendre
des éléments des réponses que j'ai fait
précédemment rappelez évidemment qu'il
ne revient pas à l'état aujourd'hui
d'interférer dans le choix d'une
rédaction du domaine privé permettez-moi
quand même peut-être d'y ajouter une
réflexion toute personnelle celle-ci
lorsque vous arrivez à la tête d'une
entreprise que vous êtes conduit et que
99% des salariés de cette entreprise
décide de se mettre en grève c'est pas
une Audain ce qui se passe au JDD
l'ensemble des journalistes ont décidé
de ne pas produire le JDD c'est la
première fois je crois en 75 ans que ça
arrive et 98% d'essayer de reconduire la
grève peut-être que vraisemblablement ce
n'est pas et l'état du droit ne permet
pas à l'état d'intervenir par contre
peut-être que si vous arrivez dans ces
conditions dans une entreprise la
question se pose de savoir si vous
prenez acte de la volonté ou non des
salariés de l'entreprise que vous venez
d'intégrer bref vous m'interrogez
monsieur le député sur l'évolution qu'on
pourrait apporter dans le cadre de la
loi Bloch je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il
y a une évolution qui a démarré de la
part des parlementaires sous les gîtes
notamment de la présidente de la
commission des affaires culturelles pour
réviser le cadre de la loi blog de 2016
la ministre de la Culture également a
engagé des travaux associant l'ensemble
des parlementaires de tous les bords
politiques qui ont souhaité y participer
parce que c'est un sujet important et
parce que c'est un sujet important
également le président de la République
souhaite l'aborder dans le cadre
généraux de l'information peut-être ces
questions que vous posez seront-elles
posées notamment comment préserver des
comités de rédaction de l'influence
d'actionnaires extérieure comment
préserver les lignes éditoriales comment
préserver encore une fois ce qui fait le
bien précieux de notre démocratie à
savoir le plus réalisme de la presse son
indépendance sa liberté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la première
ministre madame la Première ministre
dimanche votre Ministre de la culture
s'est cru autorisé à se mêler de la
ligne éditoriale d'un journal français
média privé et à s'exprimer publiquement
sur le recrutement de l'un de ces
journalistes que la ministre de la
Culture décerne des certificats de
valeurs républicaines aux journaux
français et particulièrement inquiétant
pour la démocratie la ministre de la
Culture et votre gouvernement devrait
avoir comme premier principe la défense
de la liberté de la presse sans que
celle-ci est à subir la pression du
pouvoir en place ce n'est pas la
première fois que Madame Abdul Malak
exerce des pressions voir des menaces
contre un organe de presse elle a menacé
les chaînes de télévision cnews et C8 là
encore media privé de ne pas voir leur
licence renouvelée et de les priver de
leur fréquence elle sort régulièrement
de son domaine de responsabilité de son
devoir de réserve pour s'attaquer à des
médias à des animateurs et à des
journalistes envers lesquels elles
cachent mal sa détestation madame la
premier la première ministre est-ce la
politique de votre gouvernement de
piétiner l'indépendance et le plus
réalisme des médias sous prétexte qu'ils
agacent le pouvoir en place
ces certes c'est certes très contrariant
mais toute la presse ne peut pas être
macroniste tout comme l'opinion
française d'ailleurs qui n'est plus
macroniste
quand allez-vous mettre fin à cette
série de pression
inacceptable démocratiquement et plus
largement quant allez-vous respecter la
pluralité politique et les oppositions
qui sont le reflet du choix souverain du
peuple
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame
les députés Caroline parmentier
une fois n'est pas coutume mes oreilles
ont saignées en écoutant votre question
madame la député
mes oreilles ont saigné madame la
députée quand j'ai cru comprendre que
vous étiez sur le point nous donner une
leçon de pluralisme et d'indépendance de
la presse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes oreilles enseignées parce que Madame
la député jusqu'à il y a 15 jours votre
parti politique dirigé par votre
président de groupe Madame Le Pen
censurer boycotter une chaîne
d'information BFM TV parce qu'elle avait
eu l'outre qui danse de faire un choix
éditorial qui consistait à recruter un
journaliste de l'émission quotidien mes
oreilles enseignées madame la députée
quand je me suis souvenu qu'en 2017
c'était le chiffre est un mec quand même
éloquent 28 sociétés de journalistes
excusées du peu qui épinglé les
principes de votre les pratiques de
votre partie après comme lame Le Pen et
décrété que des journalistes n'en
étaient pas ciblant ainsi quotidien
excusez du peu l'AFP excusez du feu
Radio France le monde ou France 24 je
crois madame la députée que ces médias
sont des médias d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont tous soutenus par les
pouvoirs publics plus que ça madame la
député ils sont chéris ils sont protégés
parce que même quand ils racontent des
choses qui ne nous plaisent pas même
quand elle est journaliste qui ne nous
reviennent pas ils font leur travail de
journaliste et c'est l'honneur de la
démocratie que de les respecter les
leçons garde les
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
allez-y comment pouvez-vous comparer des
relations parfois tumultueuses ce qui
est vraiment fréquemment le cas entre
les médias et Macron avec l'ingérence
d'une ministre de la Culture qui
distribue les aides
vous venez de faire la preuve de votre
malaise nous ne voulons pas nous
retrouver en Corée du Nord
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
Alexandre pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail
traversez la rue faites le tour du
vieux-portez un hélico boulot vivait
dans le monde d'Emmanuel Macron dans la
vraie vie notre pays compte plus de 5
millions de chômeurs pour
364 364
000 emplois vakan vous stigmatisez les
chômeurs alors que nous devrions tendre
la main à ceux qui sont dans la
difficulté on dirait que voudriez que
les pauvres et hontes d'être pauvre en
quoi suspendre diminuer la location de
607 euros aiderait à trouver un emploi
votre vision est dogmatique et
démagogique qui ici a déjà vécu avec 6 à
7 euros par mois
vous avez présenté un projet de loi de
refonte du service public de l'emploi
afin de conditionner le versement du RSA
à 15 à 20h d'activités qu'en est-il de
l'expérimentation improvisée dans 18
départements dans l'Aveyron
l'expérimentation a débuté le 9 mai j'ai
rencontré de nombreux travailleurs
sociaux très inquiets de nombreuses
allocataires au RSA ont besoin d'un
accompagnement global et individualisé
et non de menaces et de sanctions aide
pour accéder au logement à la mobilité
pour accéder à des soins de santé pour
pouvoir postuler un emploi il faut aussi
avoir la capacité physique et psychique
quoi qu'en disent Emmanuel Macron
serveur est un vrai métier qui ne
s'improvise pas or les sommes consacrées
à la campagne mensociale et
professionnelle des demandeurs d'emploi
sont passés de 20% du montant des
allocations dans les années 90 à 7%
aujourd'hui voici ce qui devrait être
visé par notre Parlement apporter des
moyens adéquats pour l'accompagnement
individualisé des locataires vous
prétendez responsabiliser des chômeurs
avec des droits et des devoirs l'état
a-t-il rempli ses devoirs quand il
laisse délocaliser ses usines et ses
emplois l'état remplit-il ses devoirs
car monsieur Macron a créé 400 000
pauvres de plus pendant son premier
quinquennat l'état remplit-il ses
devoirs quand 10 millions de personnes
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
vous m'interrogez sur la réforme que
nous portons réforme de l'accompagnement
du RSA c'est le député cette fausse
route en réalité faites fausse route
parce que ce que nous faisons ce que
nous proposons est ce que le Sénat va
adopter dans quelques jours c'est
justement de réinvestir massivement dans
l'accompagnement pour faire en sorte que
nous n'ayons plus à connaître les
chiffres que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui son GS simplement un instant
qu'aujourd'hui 7 ans 7 ans après une
première inscription à RSA 42% des
allocataires sont toujours au RSA de
manière continue ou récurrente est-ce
que c'est ce modèle là que vous voulez
défendre songez que aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit vous-même les moyens
consacrer à l'insertion au fond du par
rapport aux obligations qui étaient
fixées en 1988 c'est ce que nous allons
corriger notre politique est quand la
matière et notre objectif plus
exactement sont très claires c'est
rappeler que nous avons de la chance
d'être dans un pays où il existe un
revenu de subsistance qui est le RSA
auquel on a accès quand on n'a pas de
revenu
se rappeler que la puissance publique
dans son ensemble un devoir qui est de
proposer un accompagnement social et
professionnel social et professionnel
parce qu'aujourd'hui seulement 43% des
allocataires ont un accompagnement
professionnel et effectivement lorsqu'il
y a un contrat d'engagement réciproque
c'est pas nous qui l'inventons c'est la
loi de Michel requin parce qu'il y a un
contrat d'accueil d'engagement
réciproque avec des activités adaptées
d'insertion et de formation pour
permettre le retour à l'emploi et
lorsque les engagements ne sont pas
tenus il y a un principe de
responsabilité qui peut aller jusqu'à la
suspension de la location vous dites
monsieur le député avoir rencontré des
allocataires et des travailleurs sociaux
en réalité monsieur le député les
habitants de l'Aveyron quand ils quand
ils vous écoutent je les plains vous
faites une description pessimiste
pathétique et Fatalis de votre
territoire heureusement heureusement
monsieur le député que dans votre
département il y a des élus comme le
président du conseil départemental qui
croit que le RSA n'est pas une fatalité
il y a des élus sur votre
circonscription qui croient que la
précarité n'est pas une fatalité votre
seul objectif c'est de l'entretenir
merci beaucoup Monsieur ministreham
Merci beaucoup
s'il vous plaît n'avez plus s'il vous
plaît madame panneau madame
[Applaudissements]
la présidente madame la Présidente
panneau s'il vous plaît vous n'avez pas
la parole la parole est à Monsieur
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur David
la parole est à Monsieur David Topia
pour le groupe yacht
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur la semaine
dernière par deux fois le Gers a été
frappé par des épisodes de
météorologiques d'une rare violence qui
a entraîné d'importants dégâts matériels
des plus torrentiels des orages des
chutes de grêle et des vins violents ont
provoqué des inondations des glissements
de terrain et des dommages considérables
aux habitations aux infrastructures
publiques aux entreprises et aux
exploitations agricoles un tiers du
vignoble et des Côtes de Gascogne a subi
des dommages conséquents
les pertes matérielles sont importantes
et de nombreuses familles sont
actuellement dans une situation précaire
et privée de bien essentiels
je tiens à celui de réactivité le
professionnalisme des ensembles de
l'ensemble des services de secours et
des services départementaux et
préfectoraux qui se sont mobilisés pour
répondre avec efficacité aux besoins des
populations touchées
dans ce contexte critique une
reconnaissance rapide de catastrophe
naturelle doit être engagée pour
permettre de débloquer les dispositifs
d'aide et de soutien approprié pour les
sinistrés et pour les collectivités
locales que ce soit en matière
d'assistance financière immédiate ou de
facilitation de procédure de
reconstruction
cette mesure d'urgence est indispensable
pour permettre une reprise rapide de la
vie quotidienne dans notre département
au-delà de cet épisode récent l'ensemble
du Sud-Ouest est confronté depuis quatre
ans à la répétition de ces phénomènes
extrêmes face à cette bascule écologique
c'est toute notre politique d'adaptation
à ce défi majeur qui doit être repensé
cela doit passer par la mise en place de
mesures d'accompagnement et de
prévention pour renforcer la résilience
des territoires mais également par des
investissements des infrastructures
résistantes des systèmes d'alerte
précoce et des programmes de
sensibilisation à la prévention des
risques naturels monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la
reconnaissance de catastrophe naturelle
sera activée par vos services dans les
plus brefs délais
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la députée mesdames et
messieurs députés monsieur le député
d'avis de topiac je voudrais à mon tour
avoir un mot pour les habitants de votre
beau département du Gers qui ont été en
effet touchés suite à une alerte météo
France le mardi 20 puis le mercredi 21
juin et suite
suite à des passages extrêmement orageux
de très nombreuses communes ont été
touchées de très nombreux agriculteurs
entreprises et particuliers vous l'avez
dit reconnu de très graves désagréments
c'est 817 interventions des
sapeurs-pompiers Rocky auquel vous avez
rendu hommage monsieur le député le
préfet qui est ouvert son centre
opérationnel d'action et puis bien sûr
les forces de police et de gendarmerie
qui ont sécurisé la zone et qui ont pu
sauvegarder la population oui je
voudrais évidemment suite à votre
demande de confirmer que à la mi-juillet
nous réunirons la commission
interministériel pour la reconnaissance
des catastrophes naturelles pour toutes
les communes du Gers pourquoi attendre
quelques jours parce qu'il faut
désormais que les communes souvent
petites puissent prendre la tâche avec
les sous-préfectures et les services de
l'État qui vont les aider j'ai donné
l'instruction au préfet du Gers pour
pouvoir déposer ses dossiers je voudrais
rappeler monsieur le député mais vous le
savez que les dégâts causés par le vent
la tempête la plus agréable sont exclus
par le législateur puisqu'il y a des
contrats d'assurance qu'en revanche les
inondations et les coulées de boue
ouvrent droit à cette reconnaissance
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas cette
reconnaissance et dans les assurances le
couvrirait pas tout notamment pour
l'espace public j'ai demandé au préfet
du Gers que la décile à deux hauteur
soit orientée pour que les travaux les
plus urgents des communes se fasse
évidemment sur ce sur ces difficultés là
je me rendrai dans votre département
pour voir l'étendue des difficultés et
durant cet été je suis sûr qu'avec vous
nous trouvons les solutions pour
accompagner chacune et chacun des
habitants du Gers chacune et chacun des
entrepreneurs et des agriculteurs merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à monsieur Carl l'olive pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre des Sports et des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques à qui
je veux dire ma flamme ma flamme
olympique et plus précisément le bonheur
de voir cette flamme traverser les
Yvelines j'y reviens
dans 395 jours pour les Jeux Olympiques
dans 428 jours pour les Jeux
paralympiques les yeux du monde seront
rivés sur notre beau pays 15000 athlètes
20000 journalistes 16 millions de
spectateurs assisteront à ces jeux et 4
millions les savons de chez eux des jeux
placés au cœur de notre temps sobres
écologique inclusif mais aussi culturel
et tournée vers les Français ces jeux
madame la ministre seront précédés d'une
magnifique fête populaire qui traversera
nos villages et nos villes celle du
relais de la flamme olympique cette
flamme allumait le 16 avril 2024 à
Olympie arrivera sur nos côtes
françaises à bord du Belém et débutera
son parcours à Marseille le 8 mai
prochain sans suivront 400 étapes dans
nos villes avec une valorisation
exceptionnelle de notre histoire notre
patrimoine naturel notre savoir-faire
notre diversité elle témoignera aussi
d'une évidence oui nous pouvons faire
nation par le sport car ces jeux de
paris seront avant tout les jeux de la
France entière apporter l'olympisme à
tous nos compatriotes et divinement
seront des témoins priv bouger le mardi
23 juillet Mantes-la-Ville
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Rambouillet
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse Les Mureaux
Guyancourt Versailles et bien sûr Poissy
si cher à mon coeur verront les 100
porteurs de la flamme se relayer je
tiens à souligner ici l'engagement des
mers et du conseil départemental des
Yvelines et de son président qui
s'implique sans relâche dans
l'investissement consacré aux
installations comme celui du passage de
la flamme madame la ministre cette
flamme c'est un symbole le symbole du
partage un symbole qui rassemble et qui
met la lumière sur le sport et notre
culture alors comment se déroulera cette
épopée comment les porteurs de flammes
seront-ils choisis comment faire rêver
nos 68 millions de compatriotes petits
et grands à s'enflammer pour ces jeux
100 ans après 1924 merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Amélie ou des accastéra ministre des
Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député car le livre
ce parcours de la flamme olympique d'une
durée inédite de 10 semaines il va être
magnifique qui va mettre à l'honneur une
France
iconique à travers toutes les régions
françaises à travers 59 départements 5
territoires d'outre-mer il va mettre en
avant ce que la France a bord son
patrimoine son patrimoine historique je
pense à Versailles je pense Mémorial de
Verdun je pense aux plages du
débarquement je pense à Lascaux dans sa
dimension aussi naturelle les vallées du
Mont-Blanc la montagne Pelée la Baie de
Somme je pense aussi à sa dimension
culturelle de Villers-Cotterêts à Cannes
en passant par le Panthéon et nos
vignobles ceux de Chablis de
Saint-Emilion je pense aussi à notre
industrie à notre ingénierie avec le
viaduc de Millau et avec le Centre
spatial de Kourou en Guyane ainsi que
notre patrimoine sportif le vélo de Rome
le stadif du manoir lindsep no Krebs
tout ça va être mis à l'honneur mais ce
parcours va être aussi l'occasion de
faire résonner nos idéaux en mettant en
avant des symboles européens forts avec
est une visite de la maison de Robert
Schuman en Moselle et des grands
marqueurs de notre démocratie je suis
fière de dire ici dans cette hémicycle
que le 14 juillet la flamme olympique
passera par l'Assemblée nationale ainsi
que par le Sénat maintenant que le
parcours est connu qu'il est dévoilé les
collectivités concernées que je veux
saluer pour leur investissement pour
leur engagement dans ce parcours et dans
sa construction vont pouvoir passer à la
phase opérationnelle de programmation
des animations festives culturelles
sportives autour de ce relais en
s'appuyant sur des comités d'engagement
territoriaux qui regorgent d'idées comme
j'ai pu le voir hier en Finistère pour
ce premier comité d'engagement
territorial dans le même temps les
collectivités vont choisir d'ici la fin
de l'année leur relayeur s'est relayeurs
des personnes inspirantes engagées pour
le sport pour le bien-être de la société
et tout ça va marquer un véritable coup
d'envoi de la mobilisation de tous nos
territoires derrière cette aventure je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à madame Isabelle Périgot
pour le couplet républicain
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche chaque semaine je reçois ma
permanence des jeunes lycéens et leurs
familles perdues dans les méandres de
parcoursup cette plateforme censée gérer
les vœux d'affectation de nos futurs
étudiants depuis 2018 date de son
lancement parcoursup et l'objet de trop
nombreuses critiques lorsqu'elles publie
ses premiers résultats cela malgré les
prétendus amélioration annoncées
successivement et qui n'ont rien changé
les lycéens leurs parents ou leurs
enseignants sont à chaque fois surpris
et des contenants sépare des résultats
parfois incompréhensibles aujourd'hui
comment expliquer que même certains
élèves avec de très bons dossiers ne
soient pas reçu dans les écoles
demandées les critères sont différents
selon les établissements et ne sont pas
lisibles sur la plateforme absence de
hiérarchisation des voeux dès les cours
pour se décider une fois que les
réponses sont positives difficultés de
gérer les listes d'attentes et bien sûr
le cas des élèves non affectés ce n'est
plus possible madame la ministre depuis
2022 et je vous avais aussi à Laté sur
cette situation plus de 10% n'avaient
pas d'offre d'affectation au dernier
jour de la phase principale que va-t-il
en être cette année et que dire de ces
jeunes qui se retrouvent dans une
filière par défaut parce qu'ils ont été
affectés sur leur quatrième choix créant
frustration absence de motivation et
surtout parfois vocation gâchées tous là
sans compter ce qui sortent de cette
plateforme en postulant directement dans
des établissements privés ce système
décourage notre jeunesse qui ne se sent
pas considérés ils ont le sentiment que
la France ne leur offre pas la
possibilité d'étudier sereinement alors
ma question est simple madame la
ministre
que comptez-vous faire pour
définitivement mettre fin à ces
situations insensées qui leur font
prendre un mauvais départ dans leurs
études supérieures je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur mesdames les députés
madame la députée Isabelle Périgot
peut-être vous répondre en trois points
d'abord vous rappelez qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait avant et qu'est-ce que vous
proposez donc avant il y avait APB et le
tirage au sort avant il y avait les
queues devant les les comptoirs
d'inscription parce qu'il fallait y en a
aller en présentiel parcoursup c'est un
outil un outil qui permet à tous les
étudiants et leurs familles d'avoir
l'ensemble de la formation la visibilité
de la formation et un guichet deuxième
point qu'il faille améliorer et que l'on
continue à écouter entendre ce que l'on
fait depuis 5 ans et améliorer et vous
avez cité des points oui nous continuons
à améliorer la transparence de cette
plateforme quand je vous entends dire
troisième point ce que nous avons fait
nous l'avons fait et beaucoup de gens
derrière cette plateforme travail et ce
que vous dites pour moi c'est aussi un
manque de respect du travail des gens
dans les lycées dans les établissements
sur la plateforme parcoursup nous avons
amélioré la transparence des
informations parce que effectivement je
vous rejoins il est important de donner
cette information et cette transparence
et cette année nous avons été plus
exigeants vis-à-vis des formations pour
améliorer cette transparence de la
formation un chiffre sur le terrain j'y
suis toutes les semaines et j'y ai été
monsieur le député pendant
30 avec eux pour voir avec les étudiants
et les élèves donc je les connais
dernier chiffre aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement 9 lycéens sur 10 à
l'instant T qui ont reçu une proposition
de parcoursup et un accompagnement qui
existe parce que notre objectif c'est de
ne laisser personne au bord du chemin je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Géraldine Bannier pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre les enseignants de lettres
classiques qui ne sont pas les seuls
concernés alerte aujourd'hui sur le
recrutement de leur père a priori le
concours 2023 risque d'être bis répétita
problématique au vu du nombre
d'admissibles le nombre de professeurs
de lettres classiques recrutés infinie
pourraient retrouver le niveau de 2022
soit 55 postes pourvu sur les 134
proposés au concours du CAPES les
résultats d'admissibilité aux capacité
externes 2023 sont
seul 47 candidats sont admissibles pour
134 postes à contrario en 2010 c'était
encore 242 candidats pour 170 postes en
2022 au comtesse seulement 160 candidats
au CAPES 425 à l'agrégation ce déficit
alarmant au tempoa mettant danger
l'enseignement du latin et du grec en
France en 2022 on comptait 14,6% de
collégiens 3% de lycée en latinistes
0,8,8% de collégiens 0,7% de lycéens et
les listes selon Le Figaro étudiant il y
a pourtant des facto des vocations je
peux en témoigner l'enseignement de ces
humanités d'une grande richesse adwitter
metternam rigueur manipulation des
langues histoire réflexion sur le
devenir des civilisations et de
l'humanité accéder à ses enseignements
exigeants et pour certains élèves un
vecteur puissants de réussite et ce à
fortiori lorsqu'on a pas toutes les
chances au départ les professeurs de les
classiques s'inquiètent aussi so facto
des difficultés consécutives mutations
difficiles voire impossible du fait de
l'absence d'options langue et culture
l'Antiquité remplacement ardu la
complémentarité des lettres classiques
et des Lettres Modernes au sein de
l'éducation nationale est une condition
sinequanone dont les langues latines
grecques et français sont entremêlées
aussi Monsieur le Ministre quelles sont
les mesures envisagées afin de
promouvoir les lettres classiques auprès
des jeunes garantir un nombre de postes
au summum pour cette merveilleuse
discipline plus généralement la question
du recrutement reste cruciale et je
profite d'un aparté je suis aussi
préoccupé que mes collègues garons et
Fanette sur la question des urgences en
Mayenne
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué chargé
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Géraldine
Bannier permettez-moi d'excuser le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse en déplacement à Marseille
avec le président de la République et
cette question nous permet bien sûr de
redire à quel point cette question du
recrutement des insultes des enseignants
et l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
est au coeur de nos préoccupations et
quelque part le gage de la de la qualité
du fonctionnement du service public de
l'éducation elle est donc bien au coeur
de nos préoccupations vous l'avez dit
madame la députée depuis plusieurs
années maintenant nous constatons une
diminution du nombre de candidats à
l'ensemble des concours recrutement des
professeurs du premier comme du second
degré alors que faisons-nous pour y
remédier nous sommes pleinement engagés
pour revaloriser ce entier essentiel
encore une fois pour la nation
essentielle pour placer l'école au cœur
de nos stratégies c'est plus d'un an de
travail et de concertation réalisée
comme le président de la République
c'était engagé lors de sa campagne
présidentielle avec des rémunérations
pour tous les personnels de l'éducation
et au premier chef bien sûr les
professeurs qui sont donc revalorisés
dès cette rentrée prochaine c'est un
budget je le rappelle historique c'est
plus de 3 milliards d'euros qui comprend
le pacte et le socle qui seront dédiés à
ces augmentations en outre le tous les
résultats d'admission ne sont pas encore
tombés madame la députée pour les
lettres classiques ce sera donc le 30
juin prochain mais les premiers
résultats montrent que notre politique
commence à porter ses premiers effets en
effet à ce stade pour la première fois
depuis maintenant plusieurs années pour
les concours du second degré de manière
globale les résultats aux différentes
phases de concours sont en aide
progression
d'inscription le taux d'inscription est
en haute de plus de 6,8% et le taux
d'admissibilité grimpe de
7,5%. en revanche comme vous l'avez dit
ce n'est pas encore le cas pour les
lettres classiques vous le soulignez cet
enseignement des humanités est
essentielles c'est donc pour cela que la
sixième est refondue avec notamment
l'enseignement du latin et du grec pour
les sessions d'approfondissement et de
soutien merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Madame Sofia shikiru pour
le groupe la France insoumise
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mon propos vise le gouvernement
mais aussi celles et ceux ici présents
qui sont des actionnaires de la
compagnie pétrolière totale énergie j'ai
rencontré Diana Kyle Maxwell et jelly 4
venus à Paris pour le sommet pour le
pacte financier mondial ils essayent
d'attirer l'attention des Français sur
les agissements de Total énergie en
Ouganda et en Tanzanie il représente
plus de 100 000 victimes du projet
d'oléoduc et à Coop et ils interrogent
comment Emmanuel Macron qui soutient
ouvertement le régime autoritaire ou
Gambais le projet climaticide de Total
hostile se présentait au monde comme un
champion de l'écologie le greenwashing
c'est peut-être vendeur ici en Europe
mais là-bas en Afrique le greenwashing
tue violation des droits de l'homme
arrestation arbitraire menace corruption
pollution destruction de la nature en
vous rangeant du côté de total vous
cautionnez ces agissements voilà
pourquoi je dénonce le double jeu de
votre gouvernement sous influence vous
parlez d'aider les pays pauvres mais la
salade que vous apportez concrètement
c'est celle qui consiste à former les
militaires ou Gandé par l'armée
française pour faire le sale boulot de
la répression des opposants au projet de
Total au moment où se discute la
directive européenne sur le devoir de
vigilance des entreprises en ce jour où
les ONG déposent plein de contre Total
devant la justice française je vous
demande de prendre vos responsabilités
allez vous cesser de soutenir ce projet
et puisqu'il y a ici des actionnaires de
total sur nos bancs n'avez-vous pas
honte de jeter dans la misère en les
privant de leur terre des milliers de
personnes comptez-vous fermer les yeux
sur les crimes commis pour protéger vos
dividendes
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je n'ai pas à commenter les activités
d'une société privée mais puisque vous
parlez du sommet de Paris pour un
nouveau pacte financier mondial
parlons-en madame la députée Paris
accueilli ce sommet rassemblant plus de
200 chefs d'État ou de gouvernement les
dirigeants des grands organisations
internationales le secrétaire général
des Nations unies des représentants de
la société civile des représentants du
secteurs privés et ce sommet a été
utile madame la députée car il a permis
de forger un consensus qui affirme que
lutte contre la pauvreté et lutte pour
la transition écologique ne saurait être
opposé je voudrais vous faire observer
que le document qui a été élu par le
Président de la République en clôture de
ce sommet l'agenda de Paris pour les
peuples et la planète associe les
gouvernements les chefs d'État le
secteur privé a déjà recueilli d'un
sentiment par écrit d'une quinzaine de
nos partenaires alors les résultats de
ce sommet pour plus de solidarité madame
la députée qui sont là et je voudrais
vous en donner quelques exemples je
pense par exemple au résultat concrets
que ce sommet a permis pour la Zambie
qui va voir sa dette restructurée elle
était en attente depuis de longues
années je pense aux petits États
insulaires qui verront une clause de
suspension de la dette en cas de
catastrophe naturelle possible ça
n'était pas le cas jusqu'ici je pense au
pays en développement qui décideront de
l'agenda de réforme qui était bien
nécessaire de la Banque mondiale où je
pense au bénéficiaire de la transition
énergétique voilà quelques exemples
alors madame la députée comment dire la
solidarité internationale il y a ceux
qui en parlent il y a ceux qui la
pratiquent et la vérité c'est que c'est
sous le mandat du Président de la
République que l'aide de la France au
développement était considérablement
augmenté et que la France est
aujourd'hui devenue le quatrième
bailleur d'aide au développement au
monde j'en suis fier soyez en fier et
soyons enfers la France agit pour la
solidarité merci madame la députée
merci beaucoup madame la ministre madame
Chikirou vous répondez à côté de la
plaque en Ouganda total et responsable
d'agissement contre les droits de
l'homme contre les droits des
communautés et la diplomatie française
là-bas on est parfaitement complice vous
devrez en rendre compte au moment venu
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Catherine Jaouen
pour le rassemblement national merci
madame le Président la présidente
question à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur le classement des villes les
plus sûrs de France n'était aux yeux ni
pour notre pays ni pour les habitants de
ma circonscription Avignon se trouve en
fin de classement plus précisément à la
264ème place sur 273 du palmarès
national le 7 décembre 2022 vous avez
opté pour la signature d'un contrat de
sécurité intégré avec la ville d'Avignon
alors même que l'état de la délinquance
caractérisée par trafic de stupéfiants
vol atteinte à l'intégrité physique
violence zemeurtre c'est
considérablement aggravé certaines
habitants allant même jusqu'à déserter
la ville
la politique sécuritaire adoptée par la
ville depuis 2014 s'est révélée
défaillante tant dans le recrutement
d'agents de police municipale 58 agents
pour 90000 habitants destinés à être sur
le terrain que dans l'investissement
nécessaire à la surveillance de la ville
le rapport de la Cour des comptes du 21
février 2023 relative au quartier de
reconquête républicaine les définit
ainsi ce sont des zones géographiques
caractérisées par des difficultés plus
importantes qu'ailleurs en 2013 le
préfet de Vaucluse qualifié déjà deux
quartiers de la ville d'Avignon de zone
de sécurité prioritaire en 2022 2023
cette quartier plus le centre-ville sont
désormais concernés c'est-à-dire la
totalité de la ville par la signature de
ce contrat de sécurité intégré vous avez
délégué une partie de vos fonctions
régaliennes et ceux au mépris de la
sécurité de l'intégrité des habitants
d'Avignon
pourquoi avez-vous fait le choix de ne
pas caractériser Avignon comme un
quartier de reconquête républicaine
alors que les chiffres de la délinquance
explosent et que tous les quartiers y
sont exposés
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs débutez madame la député je
souhaite évidemment vous féliciter pour
votre élection comme député puisque vous
remplacez monsieur Joris Evrard qui
était débuté et Rennes qui suite
l'inauguration l'association d'une
mosquée franco-auturk ne siège plus
parmi nous
ce qui je crois que c'est le cas je
crois que le député de Madame le début
du RN a quand même inauguré une mosquée
franco-turque et que vous l'avez exclu
de votre groupe voilà je pense qu'il
faut quand même le dire pour que les
citoyens l'ont vu vous pensiez que ça ne
se verrait pas ça c'est un peu vu
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
vous auriez su alors madame puisqu'on a
discuté avec votre prédécesseur avec qui
j'avais eu un échange que nous sommes
passés dans le département du Gard de
383 députés à 474 députés pardon
policiers plus une unité plus une unité
unité de CRS j'ai un désaccord avec le
maire de Nîmes
[Musique]
j'ai un désaccord pour le pardon pour le
département du Vaucluse j'ai un
désaccord j'ai un désaccord j'ai un
désaccord avec le maire de Nîmes ce qui
fait que non madame je n'ai pas signé le
contrat de sécurité intérieure
j'ai un désaccord j'ai un désaccord avec
la mère d'Avignon
excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
même si
même si je veux dire que dans votre
département
nous avons eu 43 % des trafics en plus
interpellés depuis un an nous avons 20%
de cocaïne saisie de plus depuis un an
et que nous avons 21 points de Deal dont
7 dans votre ville qui ont été
démantelés je veux dire madame la
députée que nous sommes prêts à
travailler avec tous les élus de la
République du moment qu'il soutiennent
les policiers qu'ils accompagnent le
déploiement de la vidéo surveillance et
qu'ils accompagnent le travail de la
police pour lutter contre l'insécurité
et pour lutter contre la drogue
[Musique]
oui
ma réponse sera ma réponse sera
nettement plus claire que la vôtre
monsieur le ministre puisque vous allez
sur le terrain des chiffres 8 65% de
délinquance en plus 20% de violence
faite aux femmes en plus en 2022 23% de
coûts et volontaires en 2022 18% des
vols avec violence je te remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Damien Adam
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Roland Lescure ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie en novembre 2022 le
président de la République a demandé au
56 industriels français les plus
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre de
présenter à l'état leur feuille de route
de décarbonation le câble fixé était
clair si les industriels s'engagés sur
une décarbonation ambitieuse l'État
serait au rendez-vous avec un soutien
public ambitieux l'industrie pèse en
France 20% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dont 55%, provient de ces 56
industriels les plus émetteurs il est
donc crucial que ces acteurs s'engagent
rapidement dans la décarbonation de
leurs activités rappelons que
l'industrie est le seul secteur
économique qui sait le plus décarboné en
France avec une baisse de 50% depuis
1990 au 2/3 grâce à les investissements
ciblés sur l'efficacité énergétique et
pour un tiers liée à la
désindustrialisation qui a supprimé 2,5
millions d'emplois étaient milliers
d'usines en 50 jusqu'à notre arrivée aux
responsabilités depuis l'élection du
président Macron et de la majorité en
2017 nous avons en effet mis fin à ce
déclassement par nos politiques
économiques et fiscales 90 000 emplois
industriels et plus de 300 usines nets
ont été créées depuis aujourd'hui nous
devons aller plus loin accélérer notre
réindustrialisation des carboner notre
économie le tout en réduisant nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
c'est tout l'enjeu du projet de loi
industrie verte que notre assemblée
étudiera d'ici quelques jours vendredi
dernier j'ai visité avec Aurore berger
l'usine Boréalis près de Rouen qui fait
partie de ses 56 les plus émetteurs
l'entreprise nous a présenté sa feuille
de route de décarbonation le même jour
la première ministre présidé une séance
du Conseil national de l'industrie dédié
à ses 56 monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous présenter les
conclusions du dernier conseil national
de l'industrie et commencer celle-ci
s'inscrivent dans la planification
écologique et l'établissement de la
stratégie française énergie climat je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup
ministre en charge de l'Industrie merci
madame la Présidente députés monsieur le
député Damien Adam merci pour votre
question le 8 novembre dernier le
président de la République à l'Élysée
nous a rassemblé nous a demandé
d'élaborer une feuille de route de
décarbonation pour les 56 les plus
émetteurs vous l'avez dit c'est 56 c'est
60% des émissions de l'industrie 45
mégatonnes de CO2 par an autant que les
logements français autant que 37
millions et demi de logements 56
industriels il y en a 6 chez vous vous
l'avez dit Boréalis Yara total énergie
et so qui a E4 représente 6 sites
industriels qui représentent 13% de ses
émissions la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les industriels ont joué le jeu ils ont
rempli leur part du contrat j'ai eu
l'honneur de présenter à la première
ministre au Conseil international de
l'esprit vous l'avez dit vendredi
dernier au Bourget la feuille de route
des 56 ils sont prêts à réduire leurs
émissions de 50% d'ici 2030 et les
éliminer totalement d'ici 2050
évidemment nous devons les accompagner
dans cette transition nous devons aussi
nous assurer que les Françaises et les
Français adhèrent à cette transition
écologique nous le faisons grâce à des
annonces effectuées dès vendredi par la
première ministre un un appel à projet
qui va soutenir la décarbonation des
principaux sites les grands et les moins
grands 1 milliard d'euros annoncé dès
vendredi 2 une enquête publique qui va
permettre d'informer les Françaises et
les Français du défi majeur de ce qu'on
appelle la capture de carbone la capture
de carbone c'est ce qui reste quand on a
tout essayé c'est quand on a du carbone
fatal on le capture et on l'envoie là où
il est venu c'est à dire en Norvège ou
ailleurs dans le sol et pour ça on a
besoin d'informer les Françaises et les
Français de ces défis là on va lancer
une grande enquête publique qui va
permettre de nous assurer qu'ensemble
nous allons remplir ce grand défi vous
l'avez dit de la décarbonation qui va
permettre de créer des sites industriels
en France évidemment derrière de
l'emploi et la prospérité merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Elisa Martin pour le
groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente cette
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre le 25 janvier 2023 le Comité
des droits de l'enfant des Nations Unies
constate que l'État français violent
plusieurs articles de la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant le
2 juin 2023 ce même comité a partagé ses
observations finales parmi elles il
regrette que malgré ses précédentes et
nombreuses recommandations la situation
des enfants demandeurs d'asile migrants
restent inchangés l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant est bafoué et ceux de façon
exponentielle et constante pendant 71
jours faute de solutions plus de 500
mineurs non accompagnés n'ont eu
d'autres choix que de se réfugier dans
une école désaffectée votre gouvernement
madame la Première ministre assume de
choisir l'abandon et l'indifférence au
détriment du respect de la présomption
de minorité pourtant fondée en droit
confronté à des conditions de vie
indécentes le 20 juin 2023 Journée
mondiale des réfugiés ces jeunes gens se
rassemblaient en face du Conseil d'État
pour faire valoir leurs droits
accompagner d'associations et de
militants alors que la police a bien
d'autres choses à faire les consignes
furent la matraque la destruction de
leur tente arrestation arbitraire et
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
placements en centre de rétention
administrative et ce malgré 11
condamnations à ce sujet par la
Commission européenne des droits de
l'homme aujourd'hui c'est 500 mineurs
sont toujours à la rue sans solution
savez-vous seulement où ils sont en tout
cas nous depuis hier soir nous
l'ignorons droit d'asile entravée
conditions de vie indécentes droit à
l'éducation niée étape psychique et
physique déplorable discrimination
systématique des tensions arbitraires
monsieur Darmanin votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur paraît condamné les propos
du RN en leur reprochant de laisser
mourir des enfants en Méditerranée
pourquoi laisser accepter vous acceptez
pour cela sur le sol français la parole
est à Madame Charlotte cobel secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'enfance
madame la présidente madame la députée
Elisa Martin à qui faites-vous ce procès
en ligne humanité et en non-respect de
l'État de droit
pas au gouvernement qui est extrêmement
clair sur ses principes tout enfant quel
que soit sa nationalité si les isolée
sur notre territoire doivent faire
l'objet du dos protection dans le
dispositif de droit commun en France le
dispositif de droit commun c'est la
protection de l'enfance qui est de la
compétence du Département vous faites
donc un procès peut-être au Département
de Paris qui est compétent pour mettre à
l'abri les mineurs sur son territoire
vous faites donc un procès à la mairie
de Paris de ne pas avoir constaté la
minorité de ses enfants vous faites
aussi un procès peut-être au juge des
enfants qui auront un statuer sur la
minorité de ses enfants dans quelques
jours vous faites donc un procès à des
personnes peut-être à la mairie de Paris
qui a choisi de ne pas utiliser le
requérir la force publique pour évacuer
cette école certes elle était dans le
16e arrondissement mais pour ne pas
évacuer cette école et donc ne pas
utiliser la force et ne pas
choisi s'il vous plaît vous n'avez pas
la parole laissez-la ministre répondre
vous faites un procès à la mairie de
Paris et au préfet de Paris qui ont
choisi de proposer de l'hébergement
d'urgence à l'ensemble de ces jeunes
gens comme vous dites vous faites
peut-être un procès aux associations qui
utilisent ces jeunes migrants pour les
mettre en situation de se mettre hors la
loi en occupant illicitement deux sites
cette école et le parvis effectivement
qui a été peut-être en tout cas moi je
ne suis pas juge je ne suis plus
procureur mais j'agis au nom du
gouvernement le ministre s'est engagé à
interdire le placement des mineurs
encras nous avons
dans ce gouvernement pour sécuriser les
mnaie nous sommes dans l'action vous
êtes dans le proc dans l'accuse
la parole est à Madame Sabrina sebahi
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce matin à Nanterre un mineur
de 17 ans a été tué à bout portant après
un contrôle routier j'adresse bien sûr à
la famille aux proches de la victime non
plus sincères condoléances tout comme le
maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
souhaite que les enquêtes ouvertes par
la justice et l'IGPN permettent de faire
au plus vite toute la lumière sur les
circonstances exactes de ce drame
monsieur le ministre nous reconnaissons
tout comme vous l'action difficile
risquée que même les forces de l'ordre
partout dans notre pays ils sont bien
souvent les premiers à répondre face aux
dangers mais l'usage des armes ne peut
et ne doit se faire que dans des cas
très précis qui représentent un danger
vital pour le dépositaire de la force
publique les images de Nanterre ce matin
sont terribles contrairement à ce qu'on
peut affirmer certains médias aucun
policier ne se trouvait devant le
véhicule lorsque celui-ci était en
mouvement leur intégrité physique
n'était manifestement pas menacée et le
tir à bout portant ne semble absolument
pas proportionné au délit commis non le
jeune homme n'a pas foncé sur les
policiers comme l'affirme les
professionnels de la récupération
politique à l'extrême droite de cette
hémicycle nous avons sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux une vidéo démentant
catégoriquement cette version cette
affaire n'est malheureusement pas isolée
pire nous constatons une hausse des cas
comme à Nice ou encore à Paris à
l'automne dernier depuis cela s'accélère
avec deux blessés graves en
Seine-Saint-Denis les 16 mai et 3 juin
et un nouveau tué le 14 juin à Angoulême
aussi Monsieur le Ministre j'aimerais
vous poser une question pourquoi dans
notre République le refus d'obtompaire
est peut-être passible d'une balle dans
la poitrine ou dans la tête auquel cas
pourriez-vous nous préciser qui parmi
notre pôle population est soumis à cette
loi d'exception pour nous il est urgent
de revenir sur la loi du 28 février 2017
cette loi est trop ambiguë dans sa
formulation et permet aux policiers une
lecture très discutable quant à l'usine
l'usage du feu monsieur le ministre si
le refus d'obtempérer est un lit qui est
passible de trois ans d'emprisonnement
et de 75000 euros d'amende il n'est pas
possible de la peine de mort
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la présidente madame
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée ce matin en effet à Nanterre
deux motards de la DOPC de la préfecture
de police ont procédé un contrôle nous
ne connaissons pas sauf les images
extrêmement choquantes que j'ai vu
personnellement comme beaucoup de
Français les conditions exactes puisque
les policiers en ce moment sont
auditionnés par les services de la
justice deux enquêtes ont été confiées à
l'IGPN et évidemment je veux aussi dire
que c'est un drame que ce jeune
conducteur de 17 ans soit mort des
suites de ce contrôle manifestement je
veux moi aussi comme le maire de
Nanterre que j'ai eu au téléphone en
début d'après-midi donc je salue aussi
les paroles républicaines qu'il a porté
médiatiquement avoir le plus rapidement
possible pour la famille de ce jeune
homme pour la ville de Nanterre mais
aussi pour la police nationale et pour
ses policiers les résultats de cette
enquête en respectant évidemment les
procédures judiciaires je veux aussi
vous dire ici que je suis très attaché à
la protection de l'innocence des accusés
et notamment de celui qui a tiré qui est
policier qui aura à rendre compte devant
son administration et devant la justice
de ses actes mais je ne suis pas juge je
ne suis pas procureur de la République
madame et je veux aussi être attentif à
la présomption des fonctionnaires de 197
fonctionnaires de police je pendant
cependant madame permettez-moi de ne pas
être totalement d'accord avec la fin de
votre question depuis la loi 2017 j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire dans de très
nombreuses échanges ici qui a eu moins
de tirs et il y a eu moins de cas
mortels qu'avant 2017 je suis désolé de
lire madame que dans de très nombreux
cas malheureusement des policiers et des
gendarmes sont morts de refus
d'obtempérer et dans de très nombreux
cas il s'agit pas de mélanger avec celui
de ce matin manifestement ce sont des
familles de policiers et de gendarmes
qui pleurent leurs enfants alors non
bien sûr le fait vous enterrer ne peut
pas être accepté mais il n'est pas non
plus bien évidemment capable d'accepter
que des policiers tirent à vous portant
sur des jeunes hommes ou des jeunes
femmes quel que soit l'âge d'ailleurs
des conducteurs et vous dire qu'on doit
respecter le deuil des familles mais la
présomption innocence des policiers
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie cochère
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail
monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'associer ma
collègue Isabelle raouche à cette
question élu d'une circonscription
frontalière une grande partie des
salariés travaillent en Allemagne depuis
de nombreux mois je suis quotidiennement
interpellé par mes concitoyens
travailleurs frontaliers qui bénéficient
de la corps cadre sur l'application de
l'article 16 du règlement européen de
2004 relatif au télétravail ce texte a
adapté la possibilité du recours au
télétravail depuis la pandémie en effet
une dérogation a été instituée afin de
permettre aux travailleurs frontaliers
de pouvoir télétravailler plus de 25% de
leur temps de travail sans que leur
affiliation à la sécurité sociale n'en
soit modifiée ni que les entreprises
subissent une modification de leur
régime fiscal malheureusement ce
dispositif prend fin au 30 juin c'est à
dire vendredi et je m'étonne de
constater que certaines entreprises ont
exprimées à mes concitoyens frontaliers
leur souhait de revenir au
fonctionnement l'intérieur à la pandémie
du fait de l'absence de renouvellement
de cet accord pourtant le télétravail
qui a permis de maintenir l'activité
économique et de sécuriser des emplois
c'est imposer aujourd'hui comme l'une
des modalités de l'organisation du
travail cette évolution s'est révélée
bénéfique pour le quotidien ne
concitoyens frontaliers diminution de
l'empreinte carbone par un usage moins
fréquent des transports meilleure
qualité de vie de plus un tel retour en
arrière pour être perçu comme une
inégalité de traitement entre citoyens
européens quand on sait que de l'autre
côté de la frontière les travailleurs
allemands peuvent bénéficier de
dispositions plus souples
il est de notre responsive
responsabilité collective de rendre
effective les libertés européennes c'est
une opportunité de décor à cette
citoyenneté d'ailleurs ma
circonscription est un témoignage
parlant des bénéfices quotidiens du
projet européen à travers des mesures
très concrètes dans la santé les secours
les mobilités l'éducation et bien sûr le
travail monsieur le ministre face à
l'inquiétude de mes concitoyens et alors
que le dispositif arrive à échéance dans
trois jours quelles réponses
pouvons-nous leur apporter merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre
du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
je sais votre implication ainsi que
celle de Madame la députéroche sur ces
questions liées aux transfrontaliers
notamment au régime social qui
s'applique aux travailleurs
transfrontaliers vous le savez pendant
très longtemps en réalité nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une phase dérogatoire
le règlement de coordination des régimes
de sécurité sociale en Europe le
règlement 883 disait et dit toujours
d'ailleurs que les les travailleurs
frontaliers pardon pouvaient travailler
au maximum un jour par semaine en
télétravail depuis leur domicile et que
s'il travaillait plus d'un jour par
semaine en télétravail leur régime
social basculer de l'état de leur
employeur vers leur État de résidence
c'est la règle qui a prévalu qui s'est
appliquée avec la totalité de nos pays
voisins pendant de très nombreuses
années à l'occasion de la crise covid
des aménagements ont été apportés des
dérogations étaient mises en oeuvre de
manière temporaire à la fin de l'année
ces dérogation sont terminées à la fin
de mois de juin 2022 un groupe de
travail multilatéral a été mis en place
et à recommander une nouvelle période de
souplesse période de souplesse et des
rogatoire au règlement de sécurité
sociale qui s'achève dans quelques jours
le 30 juin 2023 dans cet intervalle un
accord multilatéral a été négocié et
aujourd'hui soumis à l'approbation des
différents États membres nous regardons
avec Madame la première mise quels sont
les conséquences exactes de cet accord
multilatéral il y a par exemple un point
qui nous pose à ce stade une difficulté
c'est le fait que le régime de
l'assurance chômage et notamment le fait
de la bascule des droits en matière
d'assurance chômage n'est pas été
intégré dans l'accord multilatérale ce
point est d'autant plus problématique
que parallèlement à ce travail là le
Conseil des ministres européens du
travail et des affaires sociales le
conseiller psy a ouvert une période de
révision de la du règlement 883 autour
de 5 piliers dont l'assurance chômage
qui parmi les 5 piliers et celui qui est
le plus problématique mais aussi le plus
important pour la France puisque l'enjeu
interne de dépenses sociales s'élève à
plus plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros la volonté que nous avons avec
la première ministre avant que nous
arrivions à la date butoir du 30 juin
c'est de pouvoir à la fois tenir
véritablement compte des conséquences de
l'accord et de son appréciation mais
aussi donner une solution à nos
compatriotes travailleurs frontaliers
dans les heures qui viennent les jours
qui viennent nous serons tranchés cela
en écho à cette révision du règlement
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues yorana ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre à transformation il
a fonction publique
l'indemnité temporaire de retraite
littéraire a été mise en place afin de
compenser la cherté de la vie dans
certains territoires
ultramarins des abus ont été menés à
mené pardon à l'augmentation régulière
de son cou et en 2008 a été voté
l'extinction progressive de ce mécanisme
qui disparaîtra en 2028 dans le cadre de
cette réforme le gouvernement central
s'était également engagé à mettre en
place un dispositif de substitution et à
faire en sorte que les économies
réalisées soient réservées à chaque
collectivité concernée 15 années ont
passé il nous attendons toujours le
résultat de cet engagement aujourd'hui
en Polynésie française
Nouvelle-Calédonie réunion un agent
ayant servi l'État perçoit une pension
complice entre 30 et 50% de son salaire
d'actif alors qu'elle dépasse les 60%
dans l'Hexagone voici donc comment
l'État reconnait ses fonctionnaires
exerçant notre maire ou l'espérance de
vie et jusqu'à 6 ans moins élevé que
dans l'Hexagone et où le coût de la vie
y est jusqu'à 55% plus élevé le comité
consultatif sur l'ITL se réunit pour la
troisième fois le 7 juillet des
partenaires sociaux souhaitent la
participation active d'expérience
ultramarin pour proposer des solutions
réfléchies et abouties jusqu'ici les
experts doivent prendre la place de le
représentant nationaux pour avoir droit
de parole alors que les expertises sont
complémentaires ma question est simple
comptez-vous monsieur le ministre
intégrer à ce comité ces experts
ultramarins aux côtés de leur
représentant nationaux afin d'aboutir
rapidement un dispositif de substitution
concerté et digne et d'apporter une
réponse au futur retraités mais aussi
aux générations oubliées qui ont pu leur
retraite depuis 2010
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Stanislas Guerini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la réputée la députée red arbelo d'abord
permettez-moi au nom de gouvernement de
vous fêter de vous souhaitez la
bienvenue pour cette première question
au gouvernement
vous m'interrogez madame la députée sur
les dispositifs de retraite des
fonctionnaires d'État ultramarins et je
veux dire c'est un sujet qui nous
mobilise le ministre d'intérieur et les
outre-mer le ministre délégué aux
outremerges Jean-François Carco et
moi-même d'abord il faut rappeler ce
qu'elle était effectivement c'est une
indemnité complémentaire dérogatoire
système de retraite sans cotisation
correspondante qui permet à des
fonctionnaires qui font le choix
d'exercer leur retraite dans des
territoires ultramarins parfois sans
même y avoir exercé d'avoir un
complément de retraite il faut dire les
choses très clairement il y a une
extinction vous l'avez rappelé qui a été
décidé en 2008 c'était il y a plus de 15
ans sur 20 ans aucun gouvernement aucune
majorité n'a remis en cause cette
extinction de ce dispositif de
dérogatoire et je vais être très clair
ça n'est pas notre intention non plus
mais elle a des conséquences sociales et
des conséquences en matière de vie chère
et donc le président de la République
avait pris cet engagement de mettre en
place un comité
est réuni l'ensemble des élus
parlementaires
ultramarins les organisations syndicales
aussi pour réfléchir et trouver des
solutions ce comité il a été installé
par ma prédécesseur en 2022 nous avons
réuni en février 2023 est effectivement
et vous y participerez il se réunira le
19 juillet prochain sous la coupe
présidente du ministre caraco et
moi-même il permettra de mettre les
scénarios sur la table les scénarios qui
sont justement
issus des contributions des élus
parlementaires et des organisations
syndicales ces scénarios ils suivront de
lignes celui de la contributivité des
dispositifs et celui de l'équité entre
les fonctionnaires nous réfléchissons à
développer des cotisations sur les
indemnités de vie cher voyez nous
réfléchissons à tous les scénarios pour
apporter des solutions aux
fonctionnaires ultramarins et de nous
retrouverons le 19 juillet prochain
merci Monsieur le Ministre allez-y
monsieur collègue je vous remercie mais
j'insiste sur le fait que la vision
ultramarine est importante nous
connaissons donc la coexistence de ces
deux visions sur tous les sujets
touchants à l'au-delà des mers la vision
ultramarine et la vision hexagonale la
réalité du terrain et la certitude de
savoir ce qui s'y passe merci beaucoup
ma chère collègues la parole est un
monsieur Arthur de la porte pour le
groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
qui n'est plus là les socialistes ont
toujours fait de la lutte contre la
corruption une priorité en créant
notamment la Haute autorité pour la
transparence dans la vie publique en
pourtant sur ce sujet nous pouvons
largement mieux faire la France ne se
classe qu'en 21e position à l'échelle
mondiale du classement de transparentie
internationale ce combat contre la
corruption c'est d'ailleurs celui d'une
association anticorps elle a fait depuis
longtemps la preuve de son utilité et
alors que son
agrément avait été accordé in extremis
en 2021 notamment à la suite de
l'intervention des socialistes celui-ci
a été annulé par une décision du
tribunal administratif il y a quelques
jours c'est une décision de justice nous
la respectons elle fait par ailleurs
l'objet d'un recours cette association
d'utilités publiques a fait l'objet
d'une nouvelle demande d'agrément auprès
des services de la première ministre ma
question est simple vous engagez-vous à
ce que les services de Matignon
examinent avec la plus grande série
hérité cette demande il faut en effet
éviter à tout prix que les 159 projets
judiciaires dans lesquels anticorps et
partie civils ne soient fragilisés mais
aussi par ailleurs que l'association
puisse continuer à exercer ses missions
essentielles à notre démocratie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Arthur de la porte
d'abord j'étais membre du gouvernement
en 2021 l'agrément accordé par Jean
Castex ne s'est pas fait de toute façon
une extrémie c'est sous la scène
pression des socialistes là vous
revisiter un petit peu l'histoire
monsieur le député c'est bien de vous
octroyer tous les mérites mais en
l'occurrence c'est une décision du
gouvernement de l'époque bon merci
d'avoir souligné que c'est pas une
décision politique qui a été rendue mais
bien une décision de justice et que
cette décision elle peut être contestée
je rappelle d'ailleurs que la justice
avait été saisie par des anciens membres
de cette association anticorps qui
eux-mêmes considéré que l'association
devait perdre son agrément bref je
rentre pas là-dedans vous l'avez dit
vous-même il y a un appel qui est en
cours vous interrogez le gouvernement
sur le sort qui sera réservé à la
demande d'un nouvel agrément qui a été
déposé par l'association anticorps bien
écoutez sachez que la première ministre
a sans délai transmis au ministre de la
Justice le demain la demande d'agrément
pour que ça puisse être examiné en tout
cas dans les meilleurs délais il me
revient pas avant examen de cette
requête de vous en donner évidemment les
les conclusions vous dire que les
procédures pénales qui sont cours dans
lesquels anticorps est constitué ne sont
pas remises en cause du fait de l'appel
qui est suspensif et qu'en revanche la
perte de l'agrément quel qu'en soit la
cause rend la constitution de partie
civils de l'association irrecevable mais
la recevabilité de la Constitution
participe s'apprécie au jour où le
jugement intervient par ailleurs vous
dire que dans le cas du projet de loi
sur la justice qui sera débattu à partir
du 3 juillet au sein de cette Assemblée
nationale cette question sera évoquée à
travers un amendement qui traite de
l'agrément et cet amendement sera
évidemment examiné avec la plus grande
attention par le gouvernement parce que
nous sommes et vous en doutez bien et
c'est un point sur lequel nous pouvons
nous retrouver tout comme vous
déterminité déterminés à lutter contre
toute forme de corruption
[Applaudissements]
nous avions là un échange monsieur le
député je crois respectueux je pense que
vous pouvez donner au ministre de la
Justice le respect qu'il mérite et ne
pas considérer pas a priori qu'il serait
enclin à prendre une décision
le garde des sceaux le garde des sceaux
et non seulement un militant de la lutte
contre la corruption mais les gardes des
sols de la République française il
mérite le respect monsieur le j'ai fini
mon temps j'ai fini mon temps voilà
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Laurence Robert
de haut pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
Santé un euro 50 supplémentaire la
consultation c'est l'augmentation des
rizoires que vous avez accordé au
médecin généraliste ce qui n'a pas
manqué de déclencher le mécontentement
des médecins et de leur syndicats dans
ma circonscription de la Haute-Marne des
généralistes ont ainsi décidé de sortir
du secteur conventionné 1 pour passer en
honoraire libre du secteur 3 et ce n'est
pas un phénomène isolé toutes les
semaines des généralistes annoncent leur
des conventionnements en conséquence sur
des consultations qui vont en moyenne
grimper jusqu'à 50 euros les Français ne
seront remboursés que de 61 centimes par
la Sécurité Sociale et si les médecins
osent sauter le pas c'est qu'ils savent
qu'ils pourront conserver l'une
patientèle plus aisée à cause du déficit
alarmant de l'offre de santé en outre
les médecins seront encore davantage
tentés de rejoindre les villes moins
rurales et plus riches ou la patientèle
pourra assumer le remboursement en plus
de pénaliser les plus pauvres c'est la
ruralité qui paiera une fois de plus la
capacité du gouvernement anticiper en
effet je ne blâme pas ici nos médecins
qui sont les moins bien payés d'Europe
avec la vague de déconventionnement qui
s'annonce les français n'auront d'autres
voix que de payer une consultation sans
remboursement tout en continuant de
verser les mêmes cotisations sociales
d'attendre des mois pour obtenir une
consultation avec un médecin
conventionné ou alors de renoncer à des
soins en dernier recours pendant ce
temps les clandestins qui n'ont pas
cotisé un seul sous pour la France
continue de bénéficier de l'aide
médicale d'État qui prend en charge
l'intégralité de leurs soins Monsieur
François Braun en février dernier
affirmé que les déconventionnement
pénaliserait encore plus les Français en
créant une médecine à deux vitesses
gouverner c'est prévoir mais
qu'avez-vous fait jusqu'ici pour éviter
la vague de déconventionnement qui
s'annonce en France je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre en charge
des professions de santé
mais de l'organisation territoriale
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Laurence Robert déo la promesse
républicaine de notre modèle social est
celle de soins pris en charge pour tous
par l'assurance maladie la convention
c'est le contrat que les médecins
passent avec l'Assurance Maladie pour
permettre que leur passion soit
remboursé et accède ainsi pleinement aux
soins c'est un contrat social passer
avec la nation la négociation d'une
nouvelle convention n'ayant pu abouti à
un accord un règlement arbitral a été
élaboré ce sont madame la députée 700
millions d'euros qui ont été mis sur la
table pour valoriser l'activité des
médecins c'est pas une paille on défie
de cet effort important mais aussi des
besoins de nos concitoyens certains
professionnels heureusement très
minoritaires quelques dizaines seulement
madame la député c'est trop mais c'est
quelques dizaines on fait le choix dans
certains territoires de remettre en
cause leurs conventionnement avec
l'assurance maladie le gouvernement y
est néanmoins très attentif ce déconfle
se décomventionnement a pour cause
de pénaliser lourdement les patients
vous l'avez souligné notamment les plus
fragiles d'entre eux mais aussi d'isoler
les professionnels qui ont fait le choix
de se mettre en marge du système de
santé le règlement arbitral contient
plusieurs dispositions la libération du
temps médical avec la prise en charge
des assistants médicaux la valorisation
de la première consultation quand ils
prennent un patient sous LDA 60 euros la
revolise revalorisation du forfait
patientel mais aussi la pérennisation
des mesures de la mission flash de l'été
et l'augmentation de 6% de la
consultation toutes ces mesures ne sont
pas anecdotiques avec le ministre
François Braun nous sommes attentifs à
entretenir le dialogue avec les médecins
c'est sur ces bases que nous pourrons
construire une nouvelle convention avec
les professionnels nous réaffirmons
notre attachement au système
conventionnel et au dialogues avec les
partenaires sociaux pour construire une
réponse durable et forte en matière
d'accès à la santé nous en appelons
aussi solennellement à la responsabilité
des médecins qui en se décomventionnant
rompent ce dialogue rompre les qualités
devant l'accès aux soins et rompre la
confiance que leur patient place en eux
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
allezzy madame la ministre vous voyez
vous pas l'ampleur du drame de l'offre
de soins dans les territoires ruraux
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
anniv Vidal pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la Ministre chargée du
handicap madame la ministre dans un an
la France aura l'honneur d'accueillir
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 une occasion unique de démontrer
notre engagement envers l'inclusion et
l'accessibilité universelle l'événement
réunira près de 15000 athlètes
olympiques et paralympiques devant 13
millions de spectateurs et 4 milliards
de téléspectateurs nous devons être à la
hauteur de cet enjeu et offrir des
conditions d'organisation irréprochables
notamment ce qui concerne l'accueil et
l'accompagnement des délégations et
spectateurs venus du monde entier y
compris celles et ceux en situation de
handicap nous avons récemment adopté des
mesures législatives nécessaires pour
assurer la bonne préparation de ces jeux
en particulier en termes d'accessibilité
que ce soit pour le centre de santé ou
pour augmenter offre de taxi équipé pour
prendre en charge des personnes
utilisatrices de fauteuil roulant ou
encore pour les transports publics
cependant il reste une préoccupation
majeure concernant l'accessibilité des
services publics et des commerces comme
le souligne l'article d'hier du Parisien
en effet la moitié des commerces dans la
capitale ne sont pas encore adaptés à
l'accueil des personnes en situation de
handicap madame la ministre je
souhaiterais connaître les mesures
concrètes que le gouvernement compte
mettre en place pour encourager et
soutenir l'adaptation des commerces en
vue de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pouvez-vous également nous
informer des initiatives visant à
améliorer l'accessibilité des services
publics ces jeux offrent une chance
inédite de faire de la France une nation
plus sportive je pense qu'ils peuvent
être aussi une formidable opportunité de
faire de notre pays une nation plus
inclusive
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à Geneviève Darius sec
ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée à nividal je vous remercie pour
votre question qui met le focus en fait
sur deux exigences la première c'est de
bien accueillir tous les visiteurs et
tous les athlètes à Paris lors de ses
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour
réussir ses jeux la deuxième c'est de
permettre que les personnes en situation
de handicap et toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap est un accès plein
et entier à tous leurs droits et
l'accessibilité est bien entendu le
sujet majeur et l'enjeu majeur pour
notre pays et la mise en accessibilité
alors les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 c'est un
formidable une formidable opportunité
pour progresser et travailler à
améliorer ce qui est quand même assez en
retard dans notre pays il faut bien le
reconnaître et se catalyseur doit être
un catalyseur pour cet accessibilité des
espaces publics des services publics et
des Services numériques puisque
des espaces et des espaces numériques et
de nos services publics merci beaucoup
madame la ministre madame Vidal madame
la ministre on peut toutefois regretter
que la mairie de Paris n'est pas
anticipée davantage cette problématique
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Antoine vers Morel marquez pour le
groupe les républicains merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre je viens ici vous parler d'un
petit village de France ce petit village
de cremeau dans ma circonscription dans
ce village comme dans tant de village de
France il y a encore une épicerie une
institutrice une mairie il y a même un
médecin
dans ce village il y a encore des
agriculteurs qui cultivent la terre des
chefs d'entreprise qui embauchent des
jeunes qui souhaitent s'y installer mais
dans ce village il y a un manque depuis
deux ans la pharmacie De crémeau est
fermée une noix de 2018 interdit en
effet la réouverture de toutes les
pharmacies dans les communes de moins de
2500 habitants des dizaines de communes
en France sont ainsi concernées il y a
un an et demi en tant que ministre de la
Santé vous avez pris l'engagement de
donner une expérimentation à la commune
pour qu'elle puisse réouvrir une antenne
pharmaceutique votre successeur Monsieur
François Brown avait pris le même
engagement il y a 6 mois et depuis nous
n'avons aucune nouvelle de la part du
gouvernement dans ce petit village de
Cremo les habitants n'ont pas l'habitude
des manifestations ou des rassemblements
pourtant hier soir avec mon collègue
Jean-Pierre tête nous étions à leurs
côtés ou près de la moitié du village
était rassemblés sur la place à la fois
pour souligner leur attachement aux
pharmaciens qui exercent une profession
difficile dans le contexte de la pénurie
de
évidemment mais également pour réclamer
de la part du gouvernement le maintien
de cet engagement hier soir monsieur le
ministre il n'y avait pas de violence il
n'y avait pas de Black Bloc pour autant
il y avait une pancarte une pancarte qui
m'a interpellé sur celle-ci était écrit
mais chez vous les plus costies ont le
droit de vote monsieur le ministre dans
la France de 2023 faut-il trois ans pour
réouvrir une pharmacie en france je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés Antoine vermeel
marquez d'abord il n'y a pas de look
dans la Loire
c'est la plus belle région de France il
n'y a plus que d'ailleurs nulle part sur
le territoire français
monsieur le député je suis très
interpellé je réponds au nom de François
Brune pardonnez-moi qui est actuellement
déplacement avec le président de la
République à Marseille très interpellé
évidemment par la situation de votre
belle votre beau village de Cremo et je
me souviens bien les engagements que
j'avais pris et les engagements que
François Brown a pris également vous le
savez en fait il y a pas un problème
politique il y a eu un problème
technique dans la mise en place
opérationnelle de la réouverture d'une
antenne de pharmacie excusez-moi la loi
est parfois très compliquée trop
compliquée et plus qu'à mon tour lorsque
j'étais au banc comme ministre ou avant
comme rapporteur général sur les lois de
santé je disais qu'il fallait faire les
lois les plus simples possibles et ne
pas adopter trop d'amendements sinon on
s'en sort plus et bien là hélas cette
pharmacie est tombée comme d'autres
effectivement dans un interstice
législatif qui nécessite des corrections
notamment pour des enjeux de facturation
ça paraît aberrant de le dire et je suis
de tout cœur avec vous et la population
de Cremo je peux vous le dire le
gouvernement a envie que cette pharmacie
rouvre et donc elle rouvrira les
discussions vont bon train avec l'agence
régionale de santé avec les élus du
territoire et je sais que vous êtes en
pointe dans ce combat que vous menez à
juste titre monsieur le député toutes
les logiques toutes les tout ce qui est
nécessaire de faire dans la loi c'est
dans le cadre de la PPL de François Val
de Frédéric Valtou qui a été adopté en
première lecture de manière à débloquer
les choses mais qu'on ne va pas attendre
que la loi soit appliquée et bien est-ce
qu'on appelle l'article 51 que nous
avions adopté il y a quelques années qui
permet au titre de l'expérimentation
d'être dans un cadre dérogatoire pour
mettre en place des solutions de bon
sens excusez-moi des fois on est là
c'est effectivement très compliqué très
technique pas de volonté politique de
mal faire au contraire on veut que cette
antenne ouvre et ça me ferait d'ailleurs
plaisir dans quand elle aura ouvert
j'espère le plus rapidement possible de
venir vous y voir
c'est bon la séance des questions et
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]